Hallo, hallo, hallo, wer ist da? Noch keiner, nicht mal der, der, der Feuer am, am Ammo-Box-Camp.
Vielleicht sind die Leute auch durch den Titel abgeschreckt. Es hat nichts mit dem zu tun, was ihr euch vielleicht denken mögt.
Äh, hört ihr mich überhaupt? Hört ihr mich? Ja, äh, okay. Man weiß ja nie.
Ah, doch jetzt. Jetzt hat's Twitch. Erster Pog. Jetzt hat's Twitch mitgekriegt.
Hat gedauert. Schon gedacht, Twitch, Twitch checkt's nicht. Oder Vodafone kackt ab.
Oder, als allererstes hab ich ehrlich gesagt gedacht, mein Mikrofon ist nicht richtig dran.
Oh, ich muss mein Mikrofon um... Ach, ich bin zu faul, mein Mikrofon umzustecken.
Das... Aber es klingt besser, wenn ich's umstecke. Aber kein Bock, mein Mikrofon umzustecken.
Keck, wait. Okay. Jetgear. Weil ihr's seid. Ich stöpsel mein Mikrofon um.
So, jetzt hört sich besser an, ne?
Take Viagra, die Hard. IQ Boost, ja, so muss das sein. Extremely Pogge.
Max, was hältst du von Mojo? Da hab ich mich ja schon mal dazu ausgelassen, einen der letzten Streams.
Wir haben das übrigens auf unserer...
...Stream-To-Do-Liste stehen.
Dass wir uns das demnächst mal angucken.
Ich hab Offstream ganz kurz mit dem offiziellen Guide schon mal durchgelesen.
Und...
Ein paar Sachen waren mir da nicht so klar. Das... Ich kann mich... Ist aber schon eine Woche her.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Zumindest...
Ich find's von der Idee her nicht schlecht, aber ich verstehe nicht, und was ich auch ein bisschen bedenklich gar schon finde, ist,
dass es kein Open Source ist.
Versteh ich nicht.
In Zeiten, wo so ziemlich alle, sogar Java, also, naja, ja doch, sogar Java,
und die Frameworks, Runtimes und Implementierungen alle Open Source sind, verstehe ich nicht, warum das Closed Source ist.
Morpheus hat ein Video zu mir, es hat viele ein Video dazu gemacht.
Ich mein, die Idee, dass man endlich... Also, es ist ja nicht der einzige Python-Compiler, gibt's ja noch mehrere,
wobei das ja nicht wirklich ein Compiler ist, sondern es ist ein Compiler plus eine Spracherweiterung im Endeffekt.
Wo ich bin?
Wo ich nicht ganz sicher bin, bei Mojo, ist, wie es aussieht mit Python-C-Extensions und sowas, ob das alles gescheit funktioniert.
Ich würd mal darauf tippen, ja, aber weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, hab ich ja ausprobiert.
Ansonsten finde ich's eine gute Sache, was sicherlich den ganzen Python-Bros gefallen wird,
die irgendwie der Meinung sind, es ist die einzige Sprache, die es gibt.
Aber gut, sie hätten sich auch was Schlechteres zum Einstieg aussuchen können.
Läuft!
Der Titel ist übrigens ernst gemeint vom Stream.
Mir tut sowas von mein Arsch weh.
Und wisst ihr auch warum?
Es hat nichts mit Hyper-Gachi zu tun und es hat auch nichts mit C++ zu tun.
Ich mein, C++ bereitet Schmerzen, aber von C++ tut einem doch nicht der Hintern weh.
Wobei man nicht sicher sein kann bei C++.
Also, bei C++ könnte auch Hinterschmerzen verursachen.
Bist du Fahrrad gefahren? Richtig!
Ja, da fühlt man sich manchmal so, aber nein.
Ich bin Fahrrad gefahren gestern, 25 Kilometer, und heute 32 Kilometer.
Ich mein, für den einen oder anderen mag das nicht lang sein.
Für mich, ich muss sagen, es ist nicht so, dass ich irgendwie voll fertig wäre oder so danach.
Max, wie kommt es, dass du auf Twitch anders heißt, weil ich Wobblos bin?
Also, ich bin nicht so, dass ich voll fertig wäre, oder so danach.
Also, der Grund ist, ich glaube, wir haben sogar ein Kommando dafür.
Der Grund ist, dass ich den Channel schon erstellt habe, bevor ich selbst streamen wollte.
Und dann habe ich den einfach weitergenommen und fand es gar nicht so schlecht,
weil es auf YouTube auch viele nervige Leute gibt.
Und wenn die Leute, das selektiert schon mal so ein bisschen vor, ja.
Wer den Weg hierhin findet, kann nicht so total bescheuert sein.
Alles Juhi, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Naja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ja, habe ich, habe ich.
Ich habe so eine Hose, so eine Hose mit einem Polster drin.
Wie heißt das hier, Amazon?
Äh, BIP.
Sowas hier in der Regel.
Natürlich, ich sehe exakt so aus, wenn ich die anhabe.
Eins zu eins.
Gut, dass die ein Bild da drin haben.
Ja, aber so ein Teil, so ein Teil habe ich auch.
Da ist ein, da ist ein, da ist ein...
Das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Das sieht man gar nicht.
Da ist ein Polster drin.
Wie die das Wichtigste nicht zeigen, Alter.
Da ist ein Polster im Poppes.
Was man irgendwie aus irgendwelchen...
Ah, hier sieht man es, glaube ich.
Guck da, ja, hier, da.
Da ist ein Polster im Poppes.
Also an der, an der Hose.
Das ist tatsächlich prakt...
Leute, Leute, wenn ich ohne Polster fahren würde,
dann würde mir ja noch mehr der Hintern wehtun.
Bei Rathosen übereinander.
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich bin, also bei meinen Ausfahrten,
ich bin ja ewig nicht Fahrrad gefahren, ne.
Also bei meinen Ausfahrten, ich habe kreislaufmäßig überhaupt nicht das Problem.
Im Gegensatz zum Rennen.
Beim Rennen bin ich da, da muss ich es ja immer übertreiben.
Hab dann irgendwas zwischen, naja, sagen wir mal so,
wenn ich mich zusammenreiße, 145, 150 Puls.
Und wenn ich normal renne, so 100...
155 oder so.
Beim Fahrradfahren habe ich keine Ahnung, irgendwie 100, 115 bis 135 oder so.
Je nachdem, ob man ein bisschen strampeln muss.
Aber ich habe beim Fahrradfahren andere Probleme.
Das erste ist, mir tut der Arsch weh.
Nach 10 Kilometern oder so.
Mir tut der Arsch weh.
Und, aber ich gehe davon aus,
dass sich das mit der Zeit noch ein bisschen legen wird.
Mir tut der Arsch weh.
Und, was ich heute auch gemacht habe,
ich muss wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mal am Sattel reinstellen, rumstellen.
Oder mal irgendein Bike-Fitting-Termin machen.
Ich habe heute zu sehr auf den Händen gehangen.
Sodass ich jetzt sowohl links als auch rechts
die Spitze von meinem Zeigefinger fühlt sich ein bisschen...
Na, taub ist das falsche Wort.
Fühlt sich ein bisschen komisch an.
Aber das liegt dadurch, dass ich halt übelst auf die Hand gedrückt habe.
Und da gehen halt Nerven durch.
Das sagt halt auch.
So, das ist das zweite.
Und, was habe ich denn ansonsten noch?
Das war es eigentlich.
Sonst tut mir nichts weh.
Und wie gesagt, am nervigsten ist es tatsächlich, dass mir der Hintern weh tut.
Aber es ging.
Also, ich hatte ganz kurz mal 158 Puls oder sowas,
als ich die Brücke rauf gefahren bin.
Volle Pulle.
Ja, siehste.
Ja.
Ich denke auch, dass sich das legt.
Dass man Schmerzen im Puppus hat.
Aber ich muss das insgesamt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen gescheiter einstellen, das Fahrrad.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich auch mal den Sattel ein bisschen hinter.
Machen, dass ich nicht so volle Pulle auf den Ärmel hängen.
Du hast doch so einen Teil für deinen Server, mit dem du den steuern kannst.
Wie heißt das Teil noch mal?
Es ist H.
Ups, wir sind groß, leicht zu großes.
Immer und es ist H.
Oder hält das?
Das wirst du aber nicht meinen, oder?
Ach, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Du meinst den KVM Switch.
Das ist ein.
Wie heißt die Landtronics, oder so?
Spider.
Ich mach mal den Streamtitel etwas weniger Gachi-Bass-lastig.
Wobei, lass das einfach so.
Du meinst das Ding hier, gell?
Bock auf eine Stelle, also auf, her damit.
Ja.
So einen Teil habe ich.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass ich das damals für 75 Euro oder irgendwas gekauft habe.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum der Scheiß so krass teuer ist.
Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an.
Man bekommt einen VGA-Port und zwei USB-Anschlüsse.
Gut, der Vorteil ist halt davon, jede 0815-Server hat halt noch so einen VGA-Port.
Und hier kannst du halt per Netzwerk drauf connecten.
Und der Technik-Kreisel ist am Start.
Kreisel-Crind.
Aber das eigentlich Coole ist,
das ist ein Produkt, wir haben das ja mal zusammen benutzt im Stream.
Das ist ein Produkt von 2009 oder sowas.
Das ist richtig alt.
Und die haben letztens ein Firmware-Update gebracht für das Ding,
dass es jetzt ein HTML5-JavaScript-Interface hat,
ohne Java, Applets und Flash und Geschiss.
Vor zwei Jahren oder so haben die das rausgebracht.
Für ein 15 Jahre altes Gerät.
Also da kann man...
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren, oder?
Ich hab mich vertippt im T...
Okay.
Ja, also das Ding meinst du, ne?
Also, ganz ehrlich, für den Preis würde ich mir das nicht kaufen.
Wir können ja mal kurz schauen.
Wir können ja mal kurz schauen, ob es das irgendwo ein bisschen billiger gibt.
Es gibt irgendwas ohne Gehäuse oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Also ich hatte richtig Glück anscheinend.
Wie gesagt, ich hab das damals für...
Ich weiß nicht genau wie viel.
75, 95 irgendwie.
Ich hab das super günstig.
Im Vergleich zu den jetzigen Preisen gekauft.
Vielleicht, das könnte sein,
dass die...
Dass damals viele ausgemustert wurden,
dass es einfach extrem viele auf Ebay gab oder so.
Hängt das Stream?
Nö, das Stream hängt nicht.
Ich seh's in meinem Vorschau.
Hier hängt nix.
Nichts. Null. Gar nix hängt hier im Stream.
Überhaupt nix.
Ebay-Kleinanzeigen.
Ach, das ist ja nicht mehr Ebay.
Das ist ja nicht mehr Ebay.
Gibt's doch gar nix hier.
Landronix.
Ah, doch hier.
300.
Aber das ist aber auch ein neuerer.
Rinserver.
Auch ein neuerer.
NTP-Zeitserver?
Was zum...
Ach so.
Ah, das ist sowas mit GPS-Modul und sowas.
Also, naja.
Gut.
Also wenn man wirklich...
Wenn man wirklich ein GPS haben möchte für eigenen Zeitserver,
dann kann man das tatsächlich super easy mit nem ESP32 mit nem GPS-Modul machen.
Da gibt's schon fix und fix und fertige.
Guck.
Also wenn man...
Ich find's bescheuert.
Das braucht niemand.
Ja, aber man kann...
ESP...
ESP32 mit GPS...
Äh...
Nee, nicht...
GPS...
Guck, da gibt es...
Da gibt es fertige Boards.
Da ist...
Da ist sogar noch mehr drauf.
Guck mal, da ist sogar noch Lora drauf und alles möglich.
Kann man sich so ein Board kaufen?
Die sind aber auch ganz schön teuer geworden, Alter.
Die gibt's bei...
Die gibt's bei AliExpress für 15 Euro.
Alter, was...
Haha, was ist mit euch los, Alter?
Das kostet bei Ali...
Okay, passt mal auf, Mann.
Das muss ich mal...
AliExpress.
AliExpress, das muss ich mal kurz vergleichen.
Was ist mit den Amazon-Preisen los?
Sind die...
Sind die komplett wahnsinnig, oder was?
Nein, die China-Chinesen kriegen nix, nix.
AliExpress.
China-Chinesen-Seite.
Auf, mach hinne.
Nicht genug.
AWS-Resort.
Nee, nee, nicht AWS.
Die benutzen ja nicht AWS.
Die haben ja eine eigene Cloud.
Da ist in China grad Hochwasser oder Erdbeben oder irgendwas.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Manchmal kann man die Chebaden, wenn man Inkognito-Modus anmacht.
Was?
AliExpress.
Ihr seid highly pepega.
Siehst du, ich sag doch, Inkognito-Modus.
Hier.
TT-Go-T-Strahl.
Weil es den T-Beam heißt.
7,66 Euro.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist...
Ah, Moment.
Das ist mit dem alten LoRa-Modul.
Aber jemand, der nur für GPS interessiert ist, ist das ja okay.
Also, wie gesagt, die gibt es relativ günstig bei den China-Chinesen.
Und da kann man sich das mit GPS holen.
Dann hat man die Zeit davon.
Gut ist.
7LQRS.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Hier.
LinkedIn-Einloggen.
Ich hab den Account...
Ich hab meinen Account hier.
Ich hab den Account hier nicht.
Beziehungsweise, ich hab ja das Login zu meinem Account allgemein.
Kann man da vielleicht Inkognito starten?
Ach, Inkognito starten geht.
Alter.
Die Seiten sind so fail alle.
Okay.
Für welches Fahrrad kann ich gleich noch was dazu sagen?
Kann ich gleich noch dazu sagen?
Die Zeit für die 5 Kilometer ist ja mega brutal, in welchem kurzen Zeitraum das so vorwärts gegangen ist.
Du meinst 5 Minuten 45 für pro Kilometer?
War das letzte, was ich gepostet hab?
Da war ich echt im Arsch danach.
Moment, wir haben ein Kommando für mein Fahrrad?
Leute.
Da müssen wir jetzt einmal kurz für die Mods.
Ja.
Ihr müsst jetzt einmal alle im Chat Mod-Check.
Ich mach mit.
Mod-Check.
Um mal unseren Mods zu huldigen.
Dass die immer so auf...
Zack sind.
Ja.
Siehste.
Sehr schön.
Okay.
Ja, siehste.
Es gehört ja auch zu einem guten Mod-Gel dabei, dass der das so antizipiert, was da so als
Questions immer rumkommen.
Massive 5-Head-Mods.
Okay.
Dann schieben wir das noch kurz vor der Schnellanzeige ein.
Korrekt.
Das ist mein Fahrrad.
Ja.
Richtig.
So sieht das aus.
Genauso schaut das aus.
Also ich verhabe nicht ganz.
Aber...
Das sieht auf jeden Fall anders aus, wie auf dem Bild.
Aber das ist das Fahrrad, was ich mir gekauft habe.
Und ich hatte ja am Anfang...
Weiß nicht, ob die hier ein Bild davon haben.
Äh, die haben nur ein Bild von der anderen Seite.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Ja.
Ich hatte am Anfang ja ein bisschen Bedenken.
Weil du hast hier nur vorne ein Ring.
Also ein Kettenblatt.
Und hinten hast du halt 11-2.
142 Ritzel, sagt da der Fachmann für.
Zumindest habe ich halt gedacht...
Ob das nicht ein bisschen wenig ist, so mit nur einem Blatt vorne?
Und kommt man da ordentlich hoch?
Man kommt ohne Probleme ordentlich den Berg hoch, Leute.
Das einzige Problem, was ich habe, ist nicht so sehr die Übersetzung,
sondern mein Oberschenkel, der noch nicht so richtig mitmacht.
Neben den anderen Sachen, die ich euch erzählt habe.
Ja.
Also, Übersetzungsmäßig ist das gar kein Problem.
Also, die Berge, die ich hochgefahren bin bisher...
Ich bin ja nicht wirklich viele Berge...
Also, viele Steigungen gefahren.
Berge schon noch gar nicht.
War sowas wie mal irgendwie die Autobahnbrücke hoch.
So am Fußgängeraufstieg da und so.
Das war dann schon mal kurzzeitig irgendwie so...
Frag mich nicht, irgendwie 13-14% oder sowas.
Aber das konnte ich ohne Probleme durchstrampeln.
Im kleinsten Gang.
Und dann war die Übersetzung fast ein bisschen zu leicht.
Da musste ich dann irgendwie ultraschnell treten,
dass das Fahrrad nicht umkippt, so lahm war das sonst.
Aber meine Oberschenkel machen es noch nicht so ganz mit.
Ja.
Also, so sieht mein Fahrrad aus.
Und das stimmt übrigens nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die...
Das wiegt 9 Kilo.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die da gewogen haben.
Das wiegt ein bisschen mehr als 9 Kilo.
Keine Ahnung, was da mit den...
Was ist das?
Da ist ein Sternchen dahinter.
Was bedeutet denn das Sternchen?
Ah, ich habe die falsche Rahmenfarbe.
Ich habe es auch ohne Pedale.
Mein Fahrrad ist ein Ticken kleiner.
Und ohne Pedale habe ich das gemessen.
Heißt im Endeffekt...
Naja, was auch immer.
Es ist trotzdem mega leicht.
Richtig, es macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied.
Da bin ich dann auch drauf gekommen.
Es macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied.
Wie rechtfertigen die den Preis?
Also es macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied so richtig.
Weil du hast trotzdem 40 zu 42.
Ich meine, du hättest bei dem anderen, hättest du dann, ich glaube, 34 zu 36 oder so gehabt.
Das heißt ein bisschen weniger vielleicht.
Aber macht keinen Unterschied.
Ja, das stimmt.
Dir fehlt halt die ganze...
Großen Gänge.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich mal 30 kmh fahre, dann kann ich das eh nicht lange.
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe noch keine Klickschuhe.
Will ich auch erstmal nicht, weil ich noch ganz schön am rumwackeln bin oftmals.
Das mache ich erst, wenn ich das andere im Schlaf kann.
Ich habe mir da so Pedale mitbestellt, die man auf der einen Seite reinklicken kann,
auf der anderen Seite sich mit dem Fuß draufstellen kann.
Also die wurden...
Direkt im Checkout-Prozess empfohlen, aber so geil finde ich das nicht,
weil du dann immer erst mal suchen musst die Seite, wo du halt mit dem normalen Schuh draufkommst.
Das heißt, ich werde vielleicht erst mal ganz normale Pedale dran machen, die auf beiden Seiten flach sind.
Also wie der Preis gerechtfertigt ist, ist eigentlich relativ einfach zu erklären.
Das ist ein...
Ich meine, die erklären es hier.
Das ist kompletter Carbon-Rahmen.
Das sind tubeless Reifen.
Das sind...
Carbon-Gabel, Carbon-Lenker, Scheiben, Dingsbums, Bremsen, elektronische Schaltung.
Das ist...
Also ich habe mir im Vorfeld ein bisschen schlau gemacht.
Das ist preis-leistungsmäßig echt nicht verkehrt.
Ansonsten kann ich es nicht wirklich einschätzen.
Aber für irgendwas muss ich ja mal meine Kohle ausgeben.
Macht mega Bock damit zu fahren.
Das einzige ist halt, mein Arsch tut weh.
Weil ich nicht gewöhnt bin.
Ja, das ist Pech, ja.
Schloss habe ich auch eins.
So ein ganz kleines, billiges.
Leichtes.
Was man einstecken kann.
Was reicht, wenn man mal kurz zum Bäcker geht.
Aber aus den Augen würde ich es damit nicht lassen.
Zwölf Kilo.
Was sperrst du damit immer so an?
So safe to go, oder?
Schauen wir uns im Stream den Raspberry Pi zusammen an.
Ja.
Aber erst morgen früh wahrscheinlich.
Nicht heute Abend.
Ich habe schon...
Ich habe schon ein Video auf.
Schon spät, ja.
Boomer müde.
Gut.
Also.
Wollte ich noch irgendwas...
Ich wollte noch irgendwas machen.
Ach ja.
Die Stellenanzeige mir angucken.
Genau.
Wo habe ich denn die hin?
Ja.
Nein.
Oh.
Moment, Moment.
Moment, Leute.
Erweiterung verwalten.
Dark Reader.
Oh, nee.
Ich habe keinen Dark Reader hier.
Monka W.
Dann müssen wir mal kurz...
Oh, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Manage Extensions.
Und Dark Reader ist doch an.
Man, Dark Reader Details kann man nicht sagen.
Allow incognito.
So.
Dark Reader.
Okay.
Nice.
Jetzt haben wir es.
Es werden keine Bewerbungen mehr angenommen.
Oh, nein.
Okay.
Also, das soll ich mir angucken.
Dann lasst uns das doch mal anschauen.
Chatge...
Wer hat die Stellenanzeige gepostet und ist das jetzt auch die richtige, die dabei rausgekommen ist?
Ja.
Ist das die, die ich gucken soll?
Ist die richtige?
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Also, wen haben wir denn da so?
Die HDI Group.
Von denen habe ich nie was gehört.
Keine Ahnung.
Gehören zu den ersten 25 Bewerbern.
Es werden keine Bewerbungen mehr angenommen.
Nice.
Hast du jetzt was zum Standort tracken im Fahrrad drin?
Das sage ich nicht.
Nee.
Habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ist das mein Smartphone?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe aktuell einfach mein Handy dabei und ich bin auch an überlegen, wie ich das
mache, weil ich habe ja da mein Navi.
Ist kein Navi, da ist ein Fahrradcomputer vorne drauf.
Und der kann theoretisch tracken aber weiß ich wie gut das funktioniert.
Vielleicht werde ich da irgendwas verstecken, irgendwo in einem Rahmen drin oder so, dass
man das tracken kann.
Muss ich mal schauen.
Ich hoffe ja eher darauf, dass es erst gar nicht geklaut wird.
Nun gut.
Junior Cloud and Operations Engineer.
Äh, AirTag ist doof.
Also, ihre Aufgaben, Verantwortung für kontinuierlichen und stabilen Anwendungsbetrieb,
sowie die Fehleranalyse und Behebung.
Ja gut, als Cloud und Operations Engineer würde ich sagen, klingt das ja mal ganz gut passend.
Bereitstellung, also diese Stellenanzeigen, es gibt ja keine Norm für Berufsbezeichnung in der IT.
So ein paar Sachen haben sich so rauskristallisiert, aber viele nennen die Sachen halt so, wie sie gerade Bock haben.
Deswegen muss man immer mal gucken, aber ich finde, das passt zumindest jetzt schon mal ganz gut zusammen.
Bereitstellung von Infrastrukturen auf eigenen Cloud-basierten Umgebungen.
Ja, ich meine, als Cloud Operations Engineer.
Entwicklung.
Standardisierung und Betreuung.
Betreuung von Containerlösungen in Kubernetes.
Ja gut, passt denke ich auch ganz gut dabei.
Aktives Lifecycle-Management von eigenen und Third-Party-Anwendungen.
Ich tue mir mit dem Wort Lifecycle-Management immer schwer, Leute.
Ich habe da schon so eine grobe Idee, immer, was im jeweiligen Kontext mit gemeint ist.
Aber für mich ist dieses Wort Lifecycle-Management immer unglaublich schwer zu greifen.
Chat, wer von euch...
Es gibt jetzt...
Es gibt jetzt ein Sub zu gewinnen.
Wer von euch schafft es, mir in maximal drei Sätzen Lifecycle-Management so zu erklären, dass ich es checke, der Erste gewinnt.
Und wenn das keiner hinkriegt, dann bin ich auch froh, weil...
Mit oder ohne Chat-GPT, wie du willst.
Problem ist, bei Chat-GPT kommt dann oftmals Mist raus.
Das hast du im Leben nicht.
Jetzt runtergeschrieben, einfach so.
Das ist das Offensichtlichste.
Okay, Leute, ich schließe da raus.
Jetzt, jetzt lass...
Chat, Chat, ich schließe da raus.
Ihr habt auch keine Ahnung.
Beziehungsweise ist es auch enorm schwierig für euch zu erklären.
Ihr habt...
Leute, Chat-GPT, pasten.
Ne, dafür gibt es jetzt keinen Sub.
Gut, also gucken wir mal weiter.
Monitoring und Dokumentation für Standardanwendungen und Infrastrukturen.
Dokumentation braucht man nicht, wenn alles immer perfekt für das Schreiben funktioniert.
Ja, finde ich.
Operations, ne, bisschen aufschreiben, was Sache ist.
Sachen überprüfen, ob sie noch laufen.
Beziehungsweise, ob irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten auftreten.
Das finde ich passt gut dazu.
Umsetzung von Anforderungen in einem agilen Team.
Okay, heute ist alles Agile, Safe, Lean und Try.
Und, wobei das eine mit dem anderen nichts zu tun hat.
Try, Solid und T-Shaped und...
Was habe ich noch vergessen?
Kanban.
Natürlich, Kanban.
Erfolgreich abgeschlossenes Hochschul- oder vergleichbare Ausbildung.
Okay, der Standardsatz schlechthin.
Erste Erfahrung mit Cloud-Technologien und relevanten Tools.
Ehrlich gesagt, finde ich, passt das nicht so hundertprozentig zusammen.
Ich meine, du sollst dich um die Entwicklung, Standardisierung, Betreuung von Containerlösungen und Kubernetes kümmern.
Du bist...
Okay, na doch, ne, ne, passt schon, passt schon, passt schon.
Das ist eine Juniorstelle.
Habe ich jetzt gar nicht hingeguckt.
Okay, das heißt, die setzen auch ein bisschen drauf.
Zumindest interpretiere ich das da so rein.
Dass man dort anfängt und zwar das zu den Aufgaben gehört, aber man da noch reinwächst.
Ja, das finde ich ja eigentlich nicht verkehrt.
Basiswissen über...
Also, zumindest rate ich jetzt das an der Stelle so.
Basiswissen über DevOps-Methoden, ICD-Pipelines und agile Arbeitsweise.
Agile Arbeitsweise definiert eh jeder ein bisschen anders.
Eigeninitiative oder in manchen Bereichen ist agile Arbeitsweise auch komplett unsicher.
Also, zum Beispiel, wenn du so ganz klassische Operating-Strukturen hast,
so einmal in der Woche ein Change-Meeting, zwei Wochen im Voraus eintragen in die Excel-Tabelle
und hast du nicht gesehen, da ist da mit Agilität nicht allzu viel hin.
Und wer das irgendwie agile nennt, nur weil es cool klingt, der untergräbt eigentlich so die ganzen Sinnhaftigkeit davon.
Eigeninitiative und Einsatzbereitschaft.
So wie gute Problemlösungskompetenz.
Ja, das kann ich tatsächlich nur unterschreiben.
Ich meine, Einsatzbereitschaft immer im Rahmen, kommt immer auch ein bisschen drauf an, wie einem die andere Seite entgegenkommt.
Aber Eigeninitiative zum Schritt halten mit der Entwicklung, so ein bisschen musst du dich so drumherum beschäftigen,
von dir aus, aus so eigenem Antrieb.
Sonst wird das auf Dauer nichts.
Kommunikationsstärke und die Fähigkeit, Gespräche ergebnisoffen zu führen, so wie gut deutsche Kommunikationsstärke.
Das ist dann so wie der Patrick mit seiner Firma.
Entweder ihr Kacknoobs, ihr kauft jetzt einfach mein Zeug oder leckt mich.
So, ich glaube, so muss man das machen.
Oh, Sätke.
Alter, warum sterben die alle?
Da mache ich mir langsam Gedanken.
Ich meine, ich bin 39.
Aber wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Kenntnisse über Prozesse der Versicherungswirtschaft wünschen uns...
Hey, da wäre ich ja genau der richtige Kandidat für.
B.U.
Bei uns steht der Mensch im Fokus.
Wir leben eine Unternehmenskultur, der Offenheit sowie Wertschätzung garantieren allen Mitarbeitern und Kandidaten Chancengleichheit.
So schaffen wir ein Umfeld, in dem das persönliche Potenzial bestmöglich entfaltet werden kann.
Ah, ja.
Ich finde es gar nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, es ist ein Junior.
Und ich finde, das spiegelt sich auch in dieser Aussage hier wieder.
Basiswissen.
Also ganz ehrlich, Jobtitel, Aufgaben und was sie so suchen, finde ich, passt recht gut dazu.
Es ist zwar immer noch recht kurz, knackig, trocken.
Wobei kurz und knackig finde ich bei Stellenanzeigen immer gut.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nichts, wo ich in wahnsinnige Verzückung geraten würde und sagen würde, oh, das muss ich mir...
Aber es klingt...
Es klingt nicht schlecht.
Ja, also es ist jetzt nicht übertriebene Euphorie nach dem Lesen oder so.
Aber es klingt passend von den Aufgaben, vom Profil her.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, ob die jetzt auch noch gescheit bezahlen.
Ja, ich denke, da kann man sich bewerben, Chatkin.
Ja.
Guckst du sowas?
Ah, live.
Live Underflow.
Er heißt doch...
Ist das ein Zweit-Channel?
Live Overflow.
Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Das ist...
Ja.
Das gucken wir uns in 37 Minuten...
Leute, wenn ich mir heute ein 37-Minuten-Video angucke, dann sind wir morgen noch nicht fertig.
PC, warum zum Teufel haben wir PC-Welt auf?
Wait a minute, bin ich hier im...
Ich bin hier im Musik-Chrome.
Da bin ich falsch.
Ich muss in den...
Ich muss in den Video angucken.
Chrome.
Gibt's das morgen vor...
Ja, ja, ja.
Morgen im Aufwachstream gucken wir uns das an.
Und da gucken wir uns auch das Video zum Raspberry Pi an.
Hast du Ideen, was die so im Bewerbungsgespräch fragen können?
Kommt drauf an, wer dabei ist.
Es kommt ein bisschen drauf an, wer dabei ist.
Weil der Personalmensch wird dich natürlich was anderes fragen als dein zukünftiger Teamleiter oder wer auch immer alles dabei ist.
Also ich denke, du wirst in der Position sicherlich, zumindest im Forschungsbericht, kannst du sicherlich, wenn da einer dabei ist, der ein bisschen Ahnung von der Technik hat, mit den ein oder anderen Cloud-Anbieter bezogenen Sachen rechnen.
Zum Beispiel zum Richtung...
Also ich...
Kosten von Cloud-Infrastruktur zum Beispiel.
Ja, dass die fragen, okay, wie würden sie das und das aufbauen?
So kosteneffizient, da kannst du denen erzählen, so nach dem Motto, man sollte nach Möglichkeit keine Azure-Functions oder so bauen, die sich selbst gegenseitig im Kreis aufrufen.
Alter, was wird da musikloser?
Haben wir nicht irgendwo Rainbow Road oder sowas?
Jawohl, Rainbow Road, beste.
Und ansonsten werden die dich die üblichen Sachen fragen.
Oh, da bin ich jetzt der Falsche, ich bin froh, dass ich das durch habe.
Also ich wurde beispielsweise im Vorstellungsgespräch gefragt, was sind Sachen, die sie so richtig...
Oder nee, was müssten wir machen, um sie so richtig aufzuregen?
Das ist so eine typische Five-Head-Psychologie-Frage von der Personalabteilung.
Und solche Sachen...
Also was du auf jeden Fall machen solltest, ist, wenn du das ernst nimmst...
Also falls du da...
Wenn du da wirklich hin willst, also es gibt ja auch Leute, die suchen sich was raus, ein bisschen zum Üben.
Aber wenn du das wirklich ernst nimmst und da auch Absichten hast, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall denen ihre Webseite mal angucken und ein bisschen schauen, ob man vielleicht schon rauskriegt, was sie so machen.
Also sind die eher AWS, Heavy, Google Cloud, Azure, wie auch immer, angelegt.
Und vielleicht mal so einen Overview-Kurs zu Kubernetes kannst du dir auch angucken, weil das ist ja eins deiner Hauptaufgaben.
Da kannst du ein bisschen mit Know-How glänzen, kannst du denen sagen, ja, der Unterschied zwischen einem Pod und einem Container und sowas in der Richtung.
Ansonsten keine Ahnung, was sie fragen könnten.
Max, hab endlich mein Wirtschaftsinformatik-Zeug in der Tasche. Auf geht's ins DevOps.
Ja dann. GLHF.
Also ich hab geantwortet, Windows administrieren müssen.
Aber das hat er nicht gelten lassen.
So, dieses Video wurde mir vorhin empfohlen.
Warum Software-Entwickler selten Karriere machen, Chat-Game.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Also ich kann euch sagen, ich bin ja kein Hauptberuflicher Software-Entwickler, danke schön für den Sub.
SAP-Consultant, ja wenn du richtig fett Kohle machen willst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man was können muss als SAP-Consultant.
Ich kenne mich selber zu wenig mit SAP aus, um einschätzen zu können, ob die SAP-Consultants, mit denen ich bisher was zu tun hatte, auch Ahnung haben, ob das gute SAP-Consultants sind.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Aber SAP ist so ein Thema.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die hörst du eigentlich relativ selten in der IT.
Das ist zum Beispiel, mit SAP haben wir Geld gespart.
Oder mit Oracle haben wir Geld gespart.
Also in der Regel kostet eigentlich SAP und Oracle nur extra.
Also richtig viel und sie haben super eklige Lizenzbestimmungen bei Oracle.
Bei SAP weiß ich nicht so sehr.
Aber Oracle hat so ziemlich die beschissensten Lizenzbedingungen, die es gibt.
Beispielsweise auch ihren Mindest-Support-Status, den du haben musst für alle Produkte, wenn du eins gekauft hast und sowas.
Ganz, ganz schwer, was Oracle da treibt.
Also Oracle hat wirklich eine Lizenzpolitik, die zum Vermeiden von weiteren Oracle-Käufen beiträgt.
Und außerdem ist der Oracle-Support auch maximal useless.
Das ist das, was ich bisher gesehen habe.
Das will ich allgemein sagen.
Aber die Tickets, die ich bisher bei Oracle gesehen habe, sind meistens voll für den Arsch gewesen.
Die einzigen, die noch schlimmer sind, was Support-Fälle sind, ist Microsoft für Azure.
Da habe ich schon Dinge...
Also ganz ehrlich, die Microsoft-Support-Fälle sind so unglaublich bescheuert gewesen bisher, was ich gesehen habe.
Machst ein Ticket auf, bla bla bla bla, wird Traffic getroppt.
Und kriegst als Antwort, wir haben verstanden, Sie haben ein Problem damit, dass im Setting XY, bei aktiviertem Setting XY Traffic getroppt wird.
Bitte versuchen Sie folgendes, schalten Sie die Diagnose-Funktion ein.
Wenn das Problem behoben ist, dann schließen Sie bitte das Ticket.
So.
Was ich über VMware gehört habe, in letzter Zeit wenig.
Auf der alten Arbeit, wo wir noch relativ...
Wo ich zumindest noch ein bisschen was mitgekriegt habe.
Von den VMware-Leuten wurde da zwar auch öfters geflamed über den VMware-Support, aber im Großen und Ganzen scheinen die halbwegs damit zufrieden gewesen zu sein.
Ich habe letztens den unsinnigsten...
Ich komme leider nicht mehr drauf, was es war.
Bei Apple.
Kennt ihr dieses Apple Support Forum?
Wo dann immer irgendwelche Inder oder keine Ahnung, wie nennt man das?
Clickworker arbeiten und nichts Sinnvolles schreiben.
Als offizielle Response.
Ich habe bei Apple nach...
Was habe ich denn bei Apple letztens gesucht?
Ich habe gesucht nach...
Also die Antwort war, geht nicht.
Aber auch nicht so richtig.
Ich habe gesucht nach...
Wie kann man...
Oh, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich...
Azure Support ist wirklich richtig Müll.
Was habe ich denn gesucht?
Ich...
Was wollte ich denn auf...
Es muss auf jeden Fall was mit meinem...
...iPhone zu tun haben.
Ich wollte irgendwas...
Apple...
Irgendwie, wie man Shortcuts im Background laufen lassen kann?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was.
Aber das habe ich glaube ich nicht gesucht.
Und die Antwort...
Die Antwort war so unglaublich dumm in diesem Support-Forum.
Und es war ein offizieller Apple-Typ.
Die wurden einfach nur gepostet, dass man sagt, dass ich sagen könnte, sie reagieren drauf.
Ich mache einen riesen Bogen um iCloud.
Ich benutze iCloud für nichts.
Ich habe auch den iCloud-Sync für alles ausgeschaltet.
Das einzige...
Tatsächlich, die aller, aller einzigste Funktion, die ich von iCloud benutze, ist...
Find My Device.
Beziehungsweise Find My Bekanntschaft, so.
Ich habe auch nicht vor, irgendwas iCloud-mäßig zu benutzen.
Wieso meiden?
Weil es sich immer weiter lock-int in das Apple-Ökosystem.
Wie ist deine Erfahrung mit externen Consultants, die bei dir mit im Team arbeiten?
Das kommt auf den Consultant an.
Also...
Ich habe schon jede Menge unfähiger Consultants erlebt, wo ich mich frage, zu was soll ich den überhaupt konsultieren?
In diesem Namen, Consultant, schwingt ja eigentlich, zumindest für mich, mit...
Das ist jemand, wenn ich selbst nicht weiter weiß, dann kann ich den konsultieren.
Dann kann ich den fragen.
Also, die weit, weit, weit überwiegende Zahl der Fälle, habe ich mich gefragt...
Was will ich den Consultant eigentlich fragen?
Bei was kann der mir eigentlich helfen?
Wir hatten mal einen...
Ich überlege gerade, wie das gewesen ist.
Ja, genau.
Jetzt weiß ich es.
Also, wir hatten mal einen, einen externen Consultant bei uns.
Der hat irgendwie zwei Wochen gebraucht, sein Notebook einzurichten.
Wo ich auch gedacht habe, was macht der so lange?
Ja.
Und auf einmal kam er dann zu mir und meinte so...
Ja Max, ich habe gehört, du kümmerst dich ja hier um unsere Git-Repos.
Erklär mir doch mal, wie ich das jetzt mache mit dem Git.
Da habe ich ihn erstmal blöd angeguckt.
Und...
Hab dann gemeint...
Ich meine, eigentlich so halb ausgesprochen.
Halb ausgesprochen.
Das war nur Spaß, habe ich zu ihm gesagt.
Wie jetzt?
Ich dachte, als externer Experte kannst du mir das jetzt erklären.
Und dann hat er gleich zurückgeruht.
Aber natürlich, ich habe ihm dann gezeigt,
wie er sich einloggen kann,
wo er die Repos findet.
Und sowas.
Er hat das mit Shit aber nicht so gehabt.
Und da denke ich mir halt, hey...
Also, so die...
Die meistverbreitetsten,
aktuellen Technologien,
die irgendwo, eigentlich nahezu jeder Firma benutzt werden,
die kann man als Experte
doch schon erwarten drauf zu haben, oder?
Ja, Soap ist mal komplett abfuck.
Ja, das ist...
Das ist meine Erfahrung mit Consultants.
Gibt aber auch...
Gibt aber auch positive Beispiele.
Beispielsweise einer...
Auf meiner neuen Arbeit.
Der ist...
Ja, eingekauft für...
So Cloud Security
Kubernetes-Geschichten.
Und der hat auch wirklich Ahnung.
Ich habe mir sogar schon überlegt,
ob ich mit dem mal nicht einen Stream hier mache,
oder ob wir ein Video aufnehmen sollen,
wo wir uns...
Also, Video weniger, aber irgendwie...
Ein Stream, wo er uns zeigen kann,
wie man seinen selbst aufgesetzten Kubernetes-Cluster
ordentlich gegen Hackermans absichert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das irgendwie hinkriegen.
Taaal...
Danke schön für den Sub.
HiIQ-Subscription, Leute.
Way too smart.
Ein ISAC-B Training?
Was ist...
Was ist ISAC-B?
International
Software Architecture
Qualification Board.
Boah, da sind schon so viele Sachen aneinander gereiht,
dass ich da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf hätte.
Man kann sich für Software Architektur
zertifizieren.
Selbst erhaltenes Ökosystem, oder?
Chatge, ich kenne diese Zertifizierung nicht.
Taugt das?
Ansonsten, ich bin der Zertifizierung
immer relativ negativ eingestellt,
weil das meistens so ein
in sich selbst erhaltenes
Geldbeschaffungssystem ist.
Ich bin jetzt Agile, ich habe ein Fahrrad.
Geht's ab?
Doch, sehe ich genauso.
Das ist eines der wichtigsten Skills
eines jeden
Informatikors,
dass der ordentlich Suchmaschinen
bedienen kann.
Okay.
Also die sinnloseste Prüfung, die ich in letzter Zeit
äh, nicht Prüfung, sinnloseste Schulung,
die ich in letzter Zeit machen müsste,
das war aber noch beim alten Arbeitgeber,
war irgend so eine Azure-Admin-Schulung.
Da wurde von irgend, da wurde,
es musste ein offizieller Microsoft-zertifizierter
Trainer machen, und der hat dann nur
offizielle PowerPoint-Sachen durchgeklickt
für zwei oder drei Tage. Es war mega lahm.
Und hat nix gebracht.
Meinst du, Google wird mal wieder besser?
Im Großen und Ganzen ist Google eigentlich
noch ziemlich gut.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich benutze in letzter Zeit
vermehrt DuckDuckGo.
In letzter Zeit ist es dehnbar,
seit den letzten Jahren über schon.
Aber DuckDuckGo ist
auch nice.
Wobei ich gar nicht weiß, was
DuckDuckGo drunter benutzt.
Benutzen die nicht Bing? Oder sowas?
Oder indexen
die selbst? Das glaube ich kaum.
Die benutzen auch Google? Okay.
Nice.
Aber die finde ich,
finde ich schon seit den letzten paar Jahren ganz gut.
Microsoft
wollte Bing an Apple verkaufen.
Naja gut,
warum nicht? Google wollte Google
auch an Yahoo verkaufen damals.
Wie das ausgegangen ist, weiß man
ja heute. Google gibt's
noch, Yahoo gibt, wobei,
gibt es die noch?
Altaba.
Ja, die gibt's
eben ja. Nun gut.
Ja, das Video
wurde mir heute empfohlen. Und zwar,
warum Softwareentwickler selten Karriere machen.
Ich meine, ich bin kein Software-, kein
hauptberuflicher, ich bin zwar Softwareentwickler, aber ich bin
kein hauptberuflicher Softwareentwickler.
Also, man könnte sagen, kein
Professional, der damit seine
Lebensunterhalt verdient.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass die
Gründe, warum Softwareentwickler
selten Karriere machen, so diesen
klassischen Karriere-Crimes,
so nach dem Motto, irgendwann
werde ich Teamleiter, dann werde ich Abteilungsleiter,
also, die haben da schlicht und ergreifend
keinen Bock drauf auf den Scheiß.
Als Softwareentwickler verdient man
genug. Es ist nicht so, also man verdient
eindeutig über der Schwelle, wo man sich
Sorgen machen muss. Und da muss man sich halt
fragen, will man sich den zusätzlichen
Stress und den ganzen Scheiß, der damit
zusammenhängt, noch geben oder nicht?
Und
dementsprechend gehe ich jetzt einfach mal
von mir aus, was das Thema Karriere
machen angeht. Ihr wisst, ich bin ein
richtig krasser Karriere-Crinder.
Ich, ich
meine so hart die Karriere, dass das
schon wieder
bei null angekommen ist.
Und dementsprechend, ich habe auch keinen Bock.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf klassische
Karriere. Das liegt daran,
weil ich erstens das gerne mache, was ich
mache, und ich
überhaupt keinen Bock darauf habe,
irgendwas mit
Personalverantwortung oder
Projektmanagement oder sowas zu machen.
Das ist ja so der klassische
Karriereweg, den viele so für sich
für sich
so sehen
irgendwie. So nach dem Motto, ja, erstmal
mache ich das, dann mache ich vielleicht ein bisschen Projektmanagement,
dann mache ich irgendwann mal Teamleitung, sonst wie.
Also, mein alter Chef hat mir mal
gesagt,
dass es eigentlich falsch
ist, wenn man
einen Teamleiter
Manager nennt.
Aus seiner Sicht.
Er hat gesagt, für ihn ist
quasi so klassisches Management
und Mitarbeiterführung eigentlich zwei
grundsätzlich unterschiedliche Dinger,
auch wenn es oftmals unter
Management zusammengefasst wird. Okay,
klingt nicht schlecht, aber
das ist nix für mich.
Und das war lange Zeit leider ja so ziemlich
der einzige Karriereweg, den
viele Unternehmen geboten haben, so nach dem
Motto, mach mal ein bisschen hier Projekt, zeig
mal was du geiles kannst, dann wirst du
vielleicht mal Teamleiter, mal Gruppenleiter, mal
Abteilungsleiter und mal was auch immer sonst noch
so für Positionen dazwischen sind.
Und da haben viele keinen Bock drauf.
Und daraufhin
haben jetzt ja viele Unternehmen realisiert,
dass das gerade für Techniker nicht so geil
ist und die da eigentlich keinen Bock drauf haben, weil
warum sollte man das machen? Sich
freiwillig fertig machen, obwohl man ja
das andere, was man sonst macht, viel lieber macht.
Deswegen gibt es jetzt meistens noch
neben diesen klassischen
Karrieremöglichkeiten noch
so ne zweite Technik-Karrieremöglichkeit,
wo sich manche Unternehmen schwerer
mit tun sowas zu implementieren,
aber da gibt es dann meistens sowas wie
Experte,
Architekt oder was auch immer,
da kannst du dann noch so ein bisschen
steigern das Ganze
und hast dann zwar auch mehr
Verantwortung, aber
eben nicht solche
Management- und
Personalführungssachen.
Das ist was, was ich mir beschränkt
noch irgendwie vorstellen könnte,
aber ehrlich gesagt,
ich glaube, ich bin am besten,
also ich kann der Firma
am besten was
für mein Geld bieten,
wenn ich Technik-Kram mache
und wenn die mich Technik-Kram machen lassen.
Was mich bei einer aktuellen Firma auch,
sagen wir mal,
naja, ganz okay machen lässt,
der Meeting-Anteil ist halt unnötig hoch.
Das habe ich auch schon 500 Mal
gesagt, aber das ist halt so.
Ich mein, ich sitz auch 50%
meiner Arbeitszeit
in irgendwelchen
sinnlosen Meetings, wo ich nicht ein Wort
sagen muss.
Also, okay, wenn die das wollen
und mir dafür fett Kohle bezahlen,
dann soll mir das recht sein,
aber ich find's natürlich ein bisschen doof,
weil ich lieber was anderes machen würde.
Also so eine Experten-Architekten-Sache
könnte ich mir eventuell
irgendwann mal vorstellen,
aber eher nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt, eher nicht.
Das müsste natürlich schon
das wirklich perfekte Gebiet sein
und ich müsste irgendwie
ein bisschen Bock
da drauf kriegen.
Ganz ehrlich,
die Position, die ich jetzt hab,
vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich kann mit technischem Know-How
glänzen, beziehungsweise
damit das machen.
Also ich werd für mein technisches Know-How
bezahlt und das ist eigentlich das,
was ich haben will.
Und letztendlich will ich ansonsten auch gar nichts großartig machen.
Es gibt genug Kohle dafür,
es wird in Zukunft wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen mehr Kohle geben.
Unter anderem auch daran,
weil's nach wie vor immer schwieriger werden wird,
Leute zu finden.
Gerade wenn du
spezifische Sachen haben willst,
mit längerer
Berufserfahrung,
wird's wahrscheinlich auch langfristig noch mehr
Kohle geben. Das heißt, warum sollte ich
irgendwas anderes machen?
Die bezahlen jetzt schon richtig nice.
Warum sollte ich noch mehr machen?
Warum sollte ich mir noch mehr Stress geben?
Für ein paar Euro mehr?
Dann lieber
weniger Stress, trotzdem
gut auskommen
und möglichst viel das machen, worauf man Bock hat.
So, das ist das, was ich mir denke, wenn's ums Thema
Karriere machen geht.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ist die
Cam in Meetings immer an? Nö.
Also auf
meinen Meetings ist die Kamera
standardmäßig nur
in unserem
Projekt Daily
an und selbst da hab ich sie nicht immer an.
Ansonsten manchmal
zum Winken, wenn ich irgendjemanden schon
eine Weile nicht mehr gehört hab. Aber
ansonsten hab ich die Kamera eigentlich aus.
Gerade wenn man sich irgendwelche Sachen
zusammen anguckt. Entweder shared einer
der Desktop, einer guckt beim anderen
oder man redet über irgendwas, da muss man
sich nicht sehen dabei.
Seh ich genauso, aber es checken ja immer mehr.
Richtig.
Ja, ich seh das genauso.
Es sind einfach viele Techniker
und das darf man auch nicht vergessen, ja.
Viele Techniker sind keine guten
Führungskräfte. Klar kannst du jetzt sagen,
es gibt Führungskräfteausbildung,
Führungskräftecoaching und sowas.
Aber du musst schon der richtige
Typ dafür sein.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du es sonst
jemals richtig hundertprozentig
überzeugend hinbekommst.
Und wenn du dich
dazu überwinden musst, was
zu machen, was dir innerlich
widerstrebt, dann ist es einfach keine
richtige Position für dich.
Und es sind viele Manager
keine guten ITler und
viele gute ITler sind keine guten Manager.
Und
manchmal kommt
ja so über zusammen,
dann hast du welche.
Aber es ist doch nicht schlimm, hat jeder so seine eigenen Stärken.
Ja, und
wenn es die Firma erlaubt, kann man ja in so
eine Richtung gehen. Dann gibt es auch ein bisschen
mehr Kohle, mehr Verantwortung, aber zumindest
nichts, was mit Personal zu tun hat.
Äh, nee, warum?
Zeig doch mal.
Ich lese immer gerne übertriebene Stellenanzeigen.
Und viele Führungskräfte
sind keine guten Führungskräfte. Ja, kommt
auch noch dazu, ja.
Ja, ich mein,
fairnesshalber muss man sagen,
es gibt auch viele Leute, die in der IT arbeiten,
wo ich mich frage, was machen die da eigentlich?
Das ist ja überall so.
Also ich würde sagen, 80-90%
der Leute sind
zwischen, sie haben überhaupt
keinen Plan von dem, was sie machen,
bis zu, ja,
Standardzeug können sie ganz gut erledigen.
Und die restlichen 10% sind
halt die, die du haben willst eigentlich.
Zumindest für Positionen, wo
man Ahnung haben muss
und keine Scheiße bauen sollte.
Es gab,
es gab mal so eine coole, ich weiß
nicht mal, wo ich das her hab. Ich hab mal ein Video
gesehen. Irgendeine
Konferenztalk.
Da hat einer so eine
Tabelle gebaut.
Oh, Moment.
Mal kurz
überskippen.
Da hat einer so eine Tabelle gebaut, so.
Und
wo ist er hier?
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob ich das jetzt
richtig, richtig
hinbekomme.
So.
Das hier war, glaube ich,
ja,
hohe Motivation
oder sowas.
Niedrige Motivation.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das jetzt so richtig hinbekomme.
So.
Oder sag mal,
nennen wir es mal anders.
Nennen wir es mal,
nennen wir es mal,
Einsatz oder,
ja, hohe Einsatz.
Einsatz, also
Antrieb, ja, meine ich jetzt.
So.
So, und hier oben
stand, oh, was war denn das?
Skill.
Also.
Hat Ahnung.
Hat keine
Ahnung. So.
Und, wie gesagt,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das jetzt zusammenkriege.
Zumindest hat er gesagt,
in diesem Vortrag, das war auch ein bisschen auf lustig
gemacht, aber ich finde, es klang schon
eindeutig.
Er hat gesagt, diese Kombination hier
ist mega selten.
Das sind die
Leute,
die willst du eigentlich
quasi für immer
bei dir behalten und
das denen so
angenehm wie möglich machen.
Weil das sind Leute, die schaffen viel,
die machen wenig kaputt,
weil sie Ahnung haben
und kriegen insgesamt viel.
So, viel auf die Reihe.
Dann gibt es Leute,
die haben Ahnung
und wenig, zeigen wenig Einsatz.
Die willst du auch haben, weil
die haben meistens ziemlich gute Lösungen.
Weil die faul sind.
Faule Leute haben die besten Lösungen.
Dann hast du Leute,
die zeigen wenig Einsatz
aber
haben auch keine Ahnung.
Da kann man ein paar von
haben, das ist nicht so wild.
Die kannst du Dinger machen lassen,
so einfache Sachen und so.
Aber das ist nicht so schlimm.
Die allerschlimmsten sind
die hier. Hoher Einsatz
und keine Ahnung.
Man würde eigentlich denken,
das hier sind die Schlimmsten, aber nein.
Das hier sind die Schlimmsten,
weil die machen dir alles kaputt.
Die sind
laufend am Machen, haben aber keinen Plan
in dem, was sie machen.
Und das sind die allerschlimmsten.
Und wenn du sowas im Management
sitzen hast,
dann hast du richtig die Arschkarte.
Wenn du so einen übereifrigen Manager
hast, der absolut keinen Plan
von seinem Job hat,
dann hast du echt ein Problem.
Und ich finde, ich weiß nicht mal aus
welchem Vortrag ich die Tabelle habe.
Tabelle, diese Grafik.
Das habe ich in irgendeinem
YouTube Konferenztalk gesehen.
Ich fand, das hat es eigentlich
wirklich ganz gut getroffen.
Ja.
Ja, das ist doch meistens so,
dass die Leute, die von sich meinen,
sie haben es am krassesten drauf,
zwar Ausnahmen gibt
von Leuten, die es wirklich krass drauf haben,
aber in der Regel ist die Kombination
es krass drauf haben
plus
so super offensiv allen zu erzählen,
man hat es krass drauf,
relativ selten,
weil es gibt ja diese schöne
Grafik so mit
steigendem Knowledge,
fällt einem auch immer mehr auf, wie kompliziert
der ganze Scheiß eigentlich ist und was es noch alles gibt,
wovon man keine Ahnung hat.
Ich finde es viel sinniger,
wenn man was Gescheites macht, es muss ja auch
gar nicht viel sein. Man muss halt
ab und zu mal was wirklich Gutes, Gescheites machen
und das kann man dann auch
breittreten überall.
Dass alle mitkriegen, dass man mal richtig
was geiles gemacht hat. Das reicht ja eigentlich
schon.
Das gibt es viele, die an der falschen Position
sitzen, die selbst dann aber auch manchmal total
unglücklich sind an der Position.
Ok, aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal
das eigentliche Video an, was ich mir angucken will.
Das waren jetzt meine Gedanken dazu
und jetzt gucken wir mal an,
was in diesem Video erzählt wird.
Moment.
Alter, das ist eine mega Idee.
Leute, ich brauche doch ab und zu mal irgendwie
halbwegs sinniges Hintergrund-Footage
für meine Videos. Ich rede ja auch über so
random Zeug in meinen Videos.
Habt mir einfach aufs Fahrrad eine GoPro,
fahr ein bisschen
durch den Wald, über die Wiese
und macht 15 Minuten sinnlose
Fahrrad-GoPro-Footage hinter das Video
und erzähle euch dann irgendwas
über
Führungskräfte in der IT und warum ich
mich mit manchen schon
gezofft habe oder warum ich manche gut und
schlecht finde und was auch immer.
Das ist dann quasi
Naturstelz 2.0.
Ist das so?
Leute, ich hatte von Anfang an
den Karriereplan, keine Karriere
zu machen.
Wusstet ihr das? Chat, stimmt das?
Habt ihr jemals,
habt ihr am Anfang gedacht,
in 5 Jahren will ich Teamleiter sein oder sowas?
Ich nie.
Ich habe mir immer nur gedacht, lasst mich mit dem Scheiß in Ruhe.
Hattest du? Okay, ja.
Gibt ja welche,
die haben die Absicht
und machen dann jahrelang
den übelsten Grind.
Beziehungsweise stellen vielleicht dann auch irgendwann fest,
es ist keine so gute Idee gewesen.
Aber kannst du nicht die Führungskraft
übernehmen, dann siehst du, dass es nicht so leicht ist?
Hä?
Das bezieht sich nicht auf mich, oder?
Das bezieht sich hier irgendwas auf Chat.
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich habe da auch
überhaupt keine Ambition. Das war letztens
schon wieder auf der Arbeit lustig.
Bei uns wurde eine Stelle ausgeschrieben
für irgendeine Teamleiterposition.
Und
ich habe
unseren IT-Chef
auf irgendeinem Meeting gefragt,
so, ja,
also warum ich gefragt habe,
der Hintergrund war,
ich kenne vielleicht jemanden,
der für diese Stelle passt.
Das war mein Hintergedanken.
Und da habe ich gefragt, sag mal,
wie ist denn das, wann werden
solche Stellen denn hier extern ausgeschrieben?
Und
wie läuft das hier
mit Bewerbungsprozess?
Ich bin ja noch neu dabei, würde mich einfach mal
interessieren. Und da meinte er, oh, jeder kann sich bewerben.
Max, du kannst dich ja auch da drauf bewerben.
Und da musste ich gleich sagen,
nee, nee, nee, nee. Nicht, dass
man mich jetzt falsch versteht. Ich habe überhaupt
keine Ambition, mich da drauf zu
bewerben.
Und schon gleich wirst du verhaftet.
Okay, auf geht's.
Hören wir uns jetzt nochmal an.
Wenn Softwareentwickler in den Berufsalltag starten,
haben sie meistens einen relativ festen Karriereplan.
Sie wissen, wann möchten sie was erreichen, welche Rolle
wollen sie vielleicht bekleiden und natürlich
auch am Ende, was wollen sie für ein Gehalt verdienen.
In der Praxis erlebe ich es aber ganz oft, dass die Softwareentwickler
sich dann doch umentscheiden und irgendwann
.net, der ist mir schon mal
sympathisch, doch keine Karriere
mehr machen wollen, egal welcher Posten
winkt, egal welches Gehalt winkt, sie wollen
einfach Softwareentwickler bleiben. Und genau das ist
der Inhalt des heutigen Videos. Nicht nur Softwareentwickler,
das ist im Prinzip ja genau das, was ich im Vorfeld
erzählt habe. Wir werden uns mal anschauen,
warum das Ganze so ist, denn ich habe da
meine Theorie, aber mehr dazu
nach dem Intro. Viel Spaß!
Wupp, wupp, wupp!
Naja,
nicht so wupp, wupp, wupp, wie ich gedacht habe.
Das kann ich gut
nachvollziehen.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Michael, 50 Billionen! Nice! Subscription,
Dankeschön!
Und für dich extra, weil du es bist.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Also in dem letzten Laden,
wo ich gearbeitet habe,
da war das auch so, immer wenn
Teamleiter oder noch mehr Abteilungsleiter,
was auch immer, Positionen frei geworden
sind und sie Bewerber dafür
intern sammeln wollten, das haben
alle immer gesagt, geh mir
mit dem Scheiß weg. Ich will es auf gar
keinen Fall machen. Das lag aber
auch daran, weil die wussten, was
das für eine Scheißposition ist.
Wir hatten bei uns sogar Teamleiter,
also die sind zurückgetreten.
Habt ihr das schon mal erlebt, Leute?
Dass
ein Großteil
der Teamleiter das
nur feststellt, sie wollen das,
dass sie zurücktreten vom Teamleiter sein?
Also das ist in der alten Firma, wo ich war, tatsächlich öfters
vorgekommen und
irgendwann, es wollte niemand mehr machen,
die haben einfach keine Leute
gefunden, die das machen wollen
und das ist
tatsächlich das Kontrastprogramm
zu dort, wo ich jetzt arbeite,
was tatsächlich eher auch für
den neuen Arbeitgeber spricht.
Dort haben die ein internes,
nennt man das so,
Führungskräfte-Förderungsprogramm,
das heißt, da wird keiner
ins kalte Wasser geschmissen,
so nach dem Motto, hey, es ist jetzt
in Führungspositionen frei,
wir brauchen da jemand, hat jemand Bock?
Nein, das ist so, du kannst sagen,
das ist was, was ich gerne machen würde
und dann machst du
zwei, drei
Jahre, kannst du dann dich
im Voraus quasi schon
anmelden
für sowas. Du musst das im Endeffekt
dann auch nie machen, wenn du nicht willst,
aber du kriegst dann zumindest schon mal die Basic-Ausbildung
für Führungskräfte.
Da kriegst du dann so Sachen wahrscheinlich
beigebracht, wie geht man
mit Mitarbeitern in Stresssituationen
um, bla bla bla, was auch immer.
Ich weiß es nicht, was man da genau macht,
weil ich habe mich da nie beworben
und ich habe es auch nicht vor,
das Programm zu machen.
Und wenn dann mal eine Position frei wird,
dann haben wir tatsächlich intern Leute,
die sagen, ja, ich will das machen
und ich bin nicht total unprepared
und planlos, weil ich die letzten zwei, drei
oder was weiß ich, schon ja
die interne Führungskräfte-Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Das finde ich, ehrlich gesagt,
relativ sinnvoll. Beim letzten Arbeitgeber
haben alle immer gesagt, oh nee, hau mal ab,
will ich nicht machen.
Kannst du kurz zeigen, welches Rad
du jetzt gekauft hast? Na, wie gut,
dass ich das noch im Hintergrund aufhabe,
weil du bist nicht der Erste, der heute gefragt hat.
Das da habe ich mir gekauft.
Die Farbe sieht aber in echt anders aus
als auf dem Bild.
Das ist Alu, das ist Carbon.
Eigentlich komplett unsinnig, so viel Geld
auszugeben für so ein Einsteiger-Ding,
aber irgendwo muss die Kohle ja hin.
Ich kann nicht alles in den ETF stecken.
Stonks.
Das Coole an dem Fahrrad ist,
also cool,
Carbon-Lenker,
Rahmen,
Tubeless-Reifen,
elektronische Schaltung,
also du hast schon coole Sachen dabei.
Nichts, was man als Einsteiger wirklich braucht,
aber nice.
Kam das
fertig montiert an?
Nicht alles.
Was man machen muss am Ende ist
Lieferzeit ungefähr eine Woche.
Nicht mal ganz,
fünf, sechs Tage.
Ich habe das
Mittwochs bestellt
und dienstags die Woche drauf kam es.
Also ja, sechs Tage oder sowas.
Kannst du einen Link posten?
Es steht doch schon im Chat drin.
Und was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen?
Ja, was ich mega nice finde,
für mich als Bustler
ist ja, ich habe hier vorne
so einen kleinen Fahrrad-Computer drauf,
man kann die Schaltung,
diese DI2
oder wie man das ausspricht, man kann die Schaltung
koppeln mit
seiner Fitness-Uhr, mit seinem Fitness-Tracker
oder mit dem Fahrrad-Computer
oder auch mit dem Smartphone
und das ist natürlich
mit dem Smartphone kannst du dann,
du kannst quasi deine Schaltung, Firmware updaten
mit dem Smartphone.
Das weiß ich, habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Was ich viel cooler finde ist
die Schaltung zu koppeln
mit dem Fahrrad-Computer
da siehst du dann
zum Beispiel auch, in welchem Gang du gerade bist
weil du hast ja hier nix
außer den Hebel, also die Gänge schaltet man
hier mit, hier schaltest du hoch
also hier wird es schwerer
ich weiß nicht, ob man das hoch oder runter schalten nennt
also hier schaltest du hoch
also hier wird es schwerer und hier schaltest du
schaltest du runter
oder umgedreht, wie auch immer
dass es leichter wird
an dem Hebel, das ist die Bremse
aber hier schaltet man das
und hier innen
drin hat man noch zwei Knöpfe
und die kann man mappen
auf seinen Fahrrad-Computer
zum Beispiel, dass der Fahrrad-Computer
den Batteriestand von der Schaltung anzeigt
und den aktuellen Gang
auf der Tour de France fahren die nicht
mit solchen komischen Fahrrädern
so
was wollte ich jetzt sagen
ja
und die Buttons hier oben
kannst du dir mappen, wireless
auf deinem Fahrrad-Computer
und dann kannst du dann damit
die Seiten auf deinem Fahrrad-Computer durchschalten
beispielsweise von der Statistik-Seite
auf die Map-Seite
und dann auf die
Anstieg-Seite, was auch immer
kannst du mit den Knöpfen hier oben machen
Spritzschutz und Beleuchtung
also irgendwelche Schutzbleche
kann man anbringen
hat der hier Montagepunkte und sowas
kann man machen
bieten die sogar an, die bieten sogar eins fertig
mit Gepäckträger und Schutzblechen an
aber brauche ich nicht
also ich habe keine Gepäckträger, keine Schutzbleche dran
was ich dran habe ist
ein Reflektor hinten dran
und ich habe eine
ein Rücklicht dran
ob man da einen Fahrradständer dran machen kann
keine Ahnung, vielleicht hier unten
ok, gucken wir weiter
eigentlich wollen wir uns das Video angucken
lul
der Lenker ist nicht gut für drücken
das geht besser als ich gedacht habe
ich hatte ja selbst so meine Bedenken
dass man da
ein bisschen
gar zu tief
sitzt, das aber
gar kein großes Ding, das ist ok
also die Sitzposition
also Rückenprobleme habe ich tatsächlich gar keine
mir tut der Arsch weh
und ich hänge mich noch viel zu sehr
in die Arme vorne auf dem Lenker
aber rückenmäßig
ist überhaupt kein Problem
das geht tatsächlich ganz gut
es ist sogar noch deutlich
bequemer finde ich
wenn man hier ganz runter greift
also am bequemsten ist natürlich
hier oben drauf
ich finde es teilweise auch echt entspannt
wenn man sich mal ein bisschen vorhängen kann
also
ich finde das nice
bis jetzt
ich bin ja wie gesagt noch nicht groß gefahren
ich bin
gestern 25 und heute
32 km gefahren
warum ich das
gleichzeitig benutze, ja mehr Browser
zur Auswahl
ich habe auch noch Firefox
also alles, gucken wir uns mal das Video an
einer meiner Kunden
der mir gesagt hat, dass am Ende des Jahres
der Abteilungsleiter
leider das Unternehmen verlassen wird
der Abteilungsleiter hat vielleicht das Unternehmen verlassen
weil er weiß, dass es irgendein komischer Laden ist
bei dem er nicht länger bleiben will, man weiß ja nie
was ja auch dafür sprechen würde
dass keiner der anderen Entwickler Bock hat, das zu machen
versucht mit den Entwicklern zusammen
eine Lösung zu finden, also mit den Entwicklern zu sprechen
wer diesen Posten übernehmen möchte
und er hat dann mit den Sätzen festgestellt, keiner der Entwickler
wollte es am Ende des Tages machen
und solche Situationen
oder ähnliche Situationen erlebe ich immer wieder
zum Beispiel, wenn ich Architektur-Workshops gebe
ist es meistens so, dass das Team
aktuell noch keinen Architekten hat
am Anfang wollen alle Architekt werden, alle finden das ganz toll
was macht er jetzt mit der Kamera
wenn er vorne angekommen ist
und wenn dann klar ist, was alles mit dieser Rolle verbunden ist
was die Aufgaben sind, was die Verantwortung sind
will das plötzlich keiner mehr machen
gleich rennt das um
wenn ich Prozess-Reviews mache, wird oft festgestellt
dass genau diese extrem wichtige Rolle des Scrum Masters
des Change Managers nicht besetzt ist
da kann man sich jetzt drüber schreiben
ob ein Scrum Master ein Change Manager sein soll
da kann man sich sicherlich im Agile Umfeld stundenlang drüber unterhalten
Chat
ja, das habe ich schon ausprobiert
ich kann es aber nicht benutzen
für alle Anwendungszwecke
weil ich gerne Platform-IO verwende
für Microcontroller
und das braucht
die offizielle C++-Extension
für Visual Studio Code
und die gibt es nur im offiziellen
zumindest war das das letzte Mal, als ich geguckt habe
nur für das offizielle Visual Studio Code
weil da proprietärer Microsoft-Shit drin ist
erkennen das Problem
und verstehen das Problem
wenn es aber darum geht, wer jetzt diese Rolle
übernehmen möchte
in der Entwicklung zurücktreten möchte
und diese Rolle Scrum Master übernehmen möchte
dann will das plötzlich irgendwie keiner mehr machen
versteht mich bei der Sache jetzt nicht falsch
es ist natürlich am Ende immer so
ich habe euch ja schon erklärt, was ich dazu denke
irgendwer findet sich das schon notfalls
wird von externen neue Personalie geholt
aber man sieht es halt
diese vakanten Positionen liegen im Unternehmen rum
es würde mehr Anerkennung bedeuten
mehr Gehalt, mehr Verantwortung
vor allem würde es
ok, es mag vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr Gehalt, je nachdem wie groß der Sprung ist
von Unternehmen zu Unternehmen
unterschiedlich, es mag mehr Gehalt bedeuten
es mag eventuell mehr Anerkennung bedeuten
ist die Frage
von wem
aber es bedeutet auch
unglaublich viel dummes Zeug
mit dem man sich auseinandersetzt
und Stress
den man sich aussetzt
den man sich ansonsten einfach nicht aussetzen müsste
Entwickler wollen diese Chance einfach irgendwie nicht ergreifen
als nächstes stellt sich natürlich die Frage
welche Karrieremöglichkeiten habe ich überhaupt
in der Softwareentwicklung
ich denke wir müssen unterscheiden auch mal
in die Karrieremöglichkeiten innerhalb des Teams
und außerhalb des Teams, also in der Unternehmensorganisation
innerhalb des Teams können wir Rollen bekleiden
wo wir für das Team und für das Produkt
mehr Verantwortung übernehmen können
wie gerade zum Beispiel angesprochen der Architekt
innerhalb von so einem Unternehmen
braucht meistens mehr Wissen, braucht mehr Ausbildung
bekommt dementsprechend meistens auch mehr Gehalt
auf der anderen Seite, gerade auch angesprochen
der Scrum Master ist für den Prozess verantwortlich
für die stetige Fortentwicklung des Prozesses
auch hier wieder mehr Verantwortung, also auch mehr Gehalt
aber auch solche Dinge wie DevOps
zum Beispiel sind meistens Zusatzqualifikationen
neben der normalen Entwicklung
wo derjenige der diese Rolle bekleidet
die Verantwortung übernimmt für den Bereitstellungsprozess
also dass das Produkt am Ende
auch tatsächlich da landet wo es in Betrieb genommen werden soll
als nächstes kann man natürlich innerhalb
der Unternehmensorganisation
innerhalb der Unternehmenshierarchie weiter aufsteigen
und das unterscheidet sich natürlich sehr sehr stark
von Unternehmen zu Unternehmen, aber wir schauen uns mal
die Level an die man in den meisten Unternehmen wiederfindet
das erste ist natürlich der Teamleiter
der Teamleiter ist derjenige
ja gut, das habe ich ja gerade auch schon erzählt
also das ist glaube ich
überall mehr oder weniger so
die Personalverantwortung für das Team hat
der also disziplinarisch dieses Team führt
ja dann hast du irgendwie noch so Gruppenleiter, Abteilungsleiter
oder vielleicht dann noch irgendeinen Direktor
oder was auch immer, es ist immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich
dass das Team sich weiterentwickelt
dass es dem Team gut geht und so weiter und so fort
darüber ist meistens der sogenannte Abteilungsleiter
der Abteilungsleiter hat mehrere Teams unter sich
und diese Teams sind meistens fachlich irgendwie gruppiert
das heißt wir haben ein Entwicklungsteam
vielleicht ein Bereitstellungsteam
ein Team für die Infrastruktur
und die wird eben verwaltet geleitet
von genau diesem Abteilungsleiter
wieder mehr Verantwortung und natürlich am Ende des Tages
auch mehr Gehalt
nächste Ebene darüber findet man oft den Hauptabteilungsleiter
oder den Bereichsleiter
der sehr sehr viele Abteilungen unter sich hat
die in einer systematischen Gruppierung gehören
Technik zum Beispiel oder Risiko oder sonst irgendwelche Dinge
das heißt der, selbe Verantwortung
er verwaltet quasi diese Abteilung
managt diese Verwaltung, kümmert sich um die Mitarbeiter
um die Strategie davon und so weiter
auch hier wieder mehr Verantwortung, mehr Gehalt
weiter oben hat man dann meistens sogenannte
technische Direktoren oder CTOs
CTO für Chief Technology Officer
und die haben dann
verschiedene Bereiche unter sich
Spätestens hier Leute
musst du das in deine Twitter-Biografie schreiben
Spätestens hier Leute musst du das in deine Twitter-Biografie schreiben
Weil die ganzen CTO-Dudes
von irgendwelchen 2-3 Mann-Klitschen
schreiben das auch immer alle fett
und ins LinkedIn-Profil natürlich
wie technisch gruppiert sind oder
nach Finanzen gruppiert sind oder was auch immer
und ganz oben on top dann besonders
in großen Konzernen ist es meistens so, dass man dann
einen Technikvorstand hat, der kontrolliert also alles
im Konzern, was irgendwie im Bereich
Technik ist oder eben auch noch Risikovorstände
oder was es da noch für Vorstände gibt
Was brauche ich jetzt, um diese Rollen überhaupt bekleiden zu können?
Nun, ich muss natürlich zu aller erst mal ein gewisses
Wissen um diese Rolle haben, das heißt
Das ist eine mega Idee
Ich finde diese Art
das ist auch super entspannt im Background
oder? Ich fahr einfach
mit meinem Fahrrad ein bisschen
durch die Felder, schnall mir
eine GoPro vorne drauf, mach
irgendwie Hyper
Anti-Shake-Gedöns
oder wie das heißt bei GoPro an
und dann habe ich easy 15 Minuten
Hintergrundmaterial
Was ist meine Aufgabe als Scrum Master
als Teamleiter, als Abteilungsleiter
was auch immer. Damit verbunden sind
Ich kann nicht labern, während ich fahre
Also
da kann ich nichts nachgucken
kann mir nichts im Vorfeld
aufschreiben, ich muss denken
fahren, reden, gleichzeitig
das funktioniert nicht
... Managementkompetenzen, dass ich also
weiß, worauf kommt das Management an
was sind die Aufgaben des Management, was ist die Zielsetzung
davon. Und genau mit diesen Managementfähigkeiten
einhergehen sind natürlich auch die
Kompetenzen, Mitarbeiter zu
führen. In all diesen Ebenen oder im Großteil
dieser Ebenen, die ich eben erwähnt habe, ist es
von Relevanz, dass wir in der Lage sind, Mitarbeiter
führen zu können, also
disziplinarisch zu walten, Konflikte
zu lösen, Mitarbeiter weiterzuentwickeln
all diese Dinge, die damit verbunden sind
Und ganz zum Schluss ist es natürlich von hoher Relevanz
dass ich in der Lage bin, wirtschaftlich zu denken
Der Scrum Master sollte den Prozess so
auslegen, dass er natürlich das Produkt und das Team
optimal unterstützt, aber gleichzeitig auch wirtschaftlich
ist. Der Architekt sollte eine Software
Entwicklung oder eine Software Architektur
Also man kann sich da echt vortrefflich drüber schreien
ob das ein Scrum Master machen soll
Eigentlich sollte ein Scrum Master
aus meiner Sicht kein Scrum Master, kein Manager
sein, sondern einzig und allein
sich darum kümmern, dass
wie auch immer man da Agilität
auslegt, dass das eingehalten
wird
Wobei hat er mit Prozess ja nicht ganz unrecht
Ja, stimmt
hat er recht
Ja
Doch, dann würde ich das
schon ausreden
Spätestens, wenn die Leute
auf die Idee kommen, dass der Scrum Master
auch gleichzeitig der Projektleiter ist, dann
kann er im Prinzip, kannst du den auch weglassen
So auslegen, dass sie auch
wirtschaftlich ist und als Teamleiter
Abteilungsleiter und so weiter ist
dieses wirtschaftliche Denken natürlich auch
absolut erforderlich. Können Softwareentwickler
das jetzt am Ende des Tages gar nicht und bekleiden
deswegen diese Rollen nicht? Das ist natürlich
nicht der Fall. Doch, doch
Ich sehe das anders, ich glaube die meisten
Softwareentwickler sind keine guten Führungskräfte
oder wären es nicht
Und das sieht man schon daran, weil
sie keinen Bock darauf haben
Irgendwie musst du da ein gewisses
einen gewissen Zug dazu auch haben
und ein gewisse, was soll man sagen
gewisse
Ja
Einfach so ein bisschen
dass man das machen möchte
Muss ich da irgendwie
so ein bisschen dazu berufen fühlen, so nach dem Motto
Ja, das ist was für mich, da habe ich Bock drauf
Aber
Ich glaube viele Softwareentwickler
beziehungsweise generell viele ITler
sind Kellerkinder wie ich
Die haben keinen Bock sich
den ganzen Tag zu 90%
mit anderen Menschen und Meetings und Sachen
auseinanderzusetzen
Die wollen Technikkrams
machen
Die wollen lieber sich mit ihrem Computer unterhalten
anstatt
mit anderen Leuten
Die wollen wie ich im Keller sitzen
ihre Ruhe haben
und Technikkram basteln
Das ist ja schon vielfältig genug
Und es ist nicht so sehr, dass die meisten
richtig Bock haben mit ihren Social Skills
zu glänzen
Ich muss sagen, für Keller bin ich dieses Jahr erstaunlich braun
Ich weiß auch nicht, was da geworden ist
Wie das so zustande gekommen ist
Alle diese Dinge, auch wenn sie teilweise
schwer zu lernen sind, kann man
in irgendeiner Art und Weise lernen
Das heißt
Kann man, kann man, sicherlich
Man kann auch Programmieren lernen
Man kann vieles lernen
Aber man braucht einen gewissen
inneren
Hang dazu, das machen zu wollen
Und wenn ich schon überhaupt keinen Bock auf andere
Mitmenschen habe, dann werde ich
bestimmt nicht Führungskraft
Das mag sein
Das mag sein, dass die heute alle
auch noch Hipster sind und mit Roller rumfahren
oder sowas, kann alles sein
Aber wenn ich eins gemerkt habe
die letzten Jahre über
Wie nennt man das so
Anekdotische Erfahrung
Also wenn ich eins die letzten Jahre
über gelernt habe, dass die Leute
die besonders viel Plan haben
Das sind Leute
Man Kellerkinder
mag das falsche Wort sein
Das sind aber Leute
die nicht einfach nur
Technikkrams machen
Ja
weil es jetzt ihr Job ist
Sondern das sind Leute
die nehmen privat
vielleicht sogar an irgendwelchen
Pentesting oder
Hacking, Wettbewerben teil
haben Github Projekte
sind vielleicht
ab und zu mal auf irgendeiner Konferenz
haben Ahnung
was in ihrem
Lieblingstechnik Umfeld gerade so
abgeht, wissen Bescheid
wenn irgendwelche neuen Programmiersprachen
rauskommen, was dann die Stärken und die Schwächen sind
haben sich das auch alles schon mal angeguckt
interessieren sich generell relativ
vielfältig für alle möglichen Sachen, guckt euch
das mal an, was wir hier im Stream schon alles
gemacht haben, wir haben von Microcontroller
Entwicklung bis
Web Interfaces
Kubernetes Cluster, wir haben alles irgendwie
schon mal irgendwo gestreift
ja und
das sind halt
einfach nicht die Leute
die
den ganzen Tag im Fitnessstudio
hängen und ansonsten
auf irgendwelchen coolen
Hipsterpartys sind
es gibt sicherlich Ausnahmen
aber die meisten
die ich kenne, da ist das so
ich sag ja nicht, dass du der komplett
ähm
dein Leben im Keller verbringen musst
und
dich nicht
traust jemand anderem in die Augen
zu gucken oder so, man muss es ja nicht übertreiben
aber
einen gewissen Hang zum
Kellerkind sein, muss es
da einfach geben
Mik Diet, dankeschön für den Sub
dein ganzes Leben ist Agile
ja genau, genau
so ist es
und dementsprechend, da fließt halt auch einfach
die Zeit rein, weil es dich eben
interessiert, unabhängig
von deinem Job
und ich hab's heute
gemerkt Leute, jetzt machen wir
nehmen wir jetzt mal mich als Beispiel
ja, weil ich nämlich so abstrakt rede
ich hab das heute gemerkt
also heute war ein nicht ganz so
normaler Tag für mich, ja
ich hab das heute gemerkt, also ich bin aufgestanden
genau, so, also
jetzt, ich muss gerade
überlegen
ich bin aufgestanden, hab was gefuttert
dann
bin ich ne Runde
rennen gewesen
dann hab ich tatsächlich
kurz
vorm Rechner gehockt
dann bin ich Mittagessen gegangen
dann hab ich nochmal kurz ne halbe Stunde
vorm Rechner gehockt
und dann war ich
zwei Stunden ins
mit drum und dran und vorbereiten
so, zwei Stunden Fahrradfahren
dann hab ich noch ein bisschen draußen
auf der Terrasse gehockt
mit der Katze
ich war legit
nicht richtig vorm Rechner
bis
keine Ahnung, bis
dann war ich nicht
am Rechner bis Abend, nach dem Abendessen
ich war erst um 18 Uhr am Rechner
so richtig
kann mir keiner erzählen, dass man in dieser
Zeit dann noch
die Energie und
Bock hat, jetzt noch
ich mach jetzt mal ein Privatrad
Softwareprojekt weiter oder sowas
ich hab jetzt Schriemen angemacht
heute Abend, ja, das war kein
so richtig normaler Tag für mich
war halt recht umtriebig
aber irgendwie ist halt auch die Zeit
begrenzt, was du machen willst
also sprich die Leute, die den ganzen Tag
Sport machen, im Fitnessstudio hängen
auf irgendwelchen Hipsterpartys sind
wann sollen die
übelst krasses, deepes
Technik-Knowledge aufbauen
das ist ja ne
schon ne reine Zeitfrage
wie soll das funktionieren
deswegen sage ich, dass viele
der richtig
guten Technikleute
schon so ein bisschen den Hang zum
Kellerkind haben, so wie ich auch
ob ich technisch jetzt Ahnung hab, sei mal dahingestellt
aber ich hab auf jeden Fall den Hang
zum Kellerkind sein
ja genau, das passt einfach nicht
du sitzt
oftmals eher
7 Stunden an irgendeinem Problem und
denkst dir, alter warum funktioniert der Scheiß nicht
und denkst dir so, oh fuck jetzt müsste ich mal langsam auch was
voran gehen
und wenn du das gemacht hast
dann ist der Tag gelaufen
dann hast du nicht so viel Zeit jetzt
zu sagen, ah ich geh jetzt nochmal kurz Fahrrad fahren
weil wahrscheinlich wird es dann demnächst schon dunkel
19 Uhr ist Sonnenuntergang
ja es ist
ich sag ja nicht, dass man das so machen muss
ich kann nur sagen, dass ich bei vielen Leuten
ich kann dich nicht aussprechen
aber Dankeschön für den Sub
dass ich bei vielen Leuten, die wirklich richtig krass den Durchblick haben
schon sagen würde
dass die ein bisschen den Hang
zum Kellerkind sein haben
und ich rede nicht so sehr von Leuten, die es nur gut
verkaufen können, dass sie richtig krass Ahnung haben
sondern Leute, von denen
ich es persönlich schon gespürt habe
dass sie Ahnung haben
gesehen habe, dass sie Ahnung haben
und das sind oftmals
ähnliche Typen Leute
so, jetzt kommen wir aber ins Video mal weiter
das ist ein bisschen schwieriger
aber das kriegt man auch noch hin, das heißt alles das könnte man
lernen, das ist also nicht die Hürde dabei
das Problem dahinter ist, und das ist meine Theorie
eine ganz andere, denn wir als Softwareentwickler
wir lieben Softwareentwicklung
wir lieben Frameworks, wir lieben Tools, wir lieben
Programmiersprachen, wir lieben es einfach jeden Tag
unsere Kreativität dazu zu nutzen
neue Software zu erstellen, Probleme
mit Hilfe von irgendwelchen IT Dingen
zu lösen, auf der anderen Seite
sind wir ja meistens nicht so
das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut, nur nicht unbedingt
für Probleme, also nicht unbedingt
für die Firma Probleme
äh, ich glaube
jeder ITler bastelt
einfach gerne
und so dieser Bas, das ist auch
was, was viele Leute
die wirklich tiefgreifend technische Ahnung
haben, was ich da auch schon eine Gemeinsamkeit
die ich da auch schon gemerkt habe ist
die Leute basteln einfach gerne
dementsprechend interessieren
die sich natürlich auch für Neues
ja, aber die basteln gerne
und das kostet Zeit
du kannst nicht sagen, ah
ich äh
ich mache, ich baue mir jetzt
mal irgendwie einen
eigenen Sensor
ich hole mir jetzt einen
ESP32 und
ich baue mir da jetzt einen eigenen Sensor
zum Fernsteuern für meine Klimaanlage
baue mir eine eigene
Firmware für
und ich mache das halt abends mal so
45 Minuten am Tag
kannst du vergessen
bis du da richtig reingekommen bist
kannst du schon ins Bett
das musst du, das musst du dann
musst du dich da einfach mal 1-2 Wochen
mit beschäftigen
kannst du natürlich auch
musst du es ja nicht jeden Tag machen
aber du wirst immer mal wieder
3-4-5 Stunden Sessions haben
wo du dich wirklich intensiv
damit beschäftigst
und so langsam aber sicher dahinter kommst
wie funktioniert denn der Kram
das kannst du nicht einfach mal sagen, ahja gut
wenn ich jetzt mit allem anderen fertig bin
dann 45 Minuten mal, das funktioniert nicht
klar man kriegt auf der Arbeit
wenn man in einem gewissen Bereich arbeitet
Mit, aber ganz ehrlich, das meiste Technik-Know-how habe ich nicht dadurch erlangt, dass ich für die Arbeit irgendwas gemacht habe, sondern es war eher umgedreht.
Ich habe mich mit irgendwas beschäftigt und ihr habt es ja hier im Stream gesehen, wir haben alles schon mal irgendwie ansatzweise gestreift.
Wir haben sogar mal Kobol im Stream gemacht, zur Belustigung des Chats.
Und es ist eher umgedreht, dass sich dadurch schon ein paar Sachen mich auf die Idee gebracht haben, hey, könnte man das nicht auf der Arbeit auch brauchen?
Und hat man ja auch oftmals dann gebraucht.
Ja gut, bei mir ist es natürlich noch besser, ich arbeite nur vier Tage die Woche, ich habe ja im prinzipiellen Tag mehr Zeit.
Und das Ding ist halt einfach, wenn du auf der Arbeit sitzt und wirst dafür bezahlt zu programmieren an irgendwas, was dich persönlich eigentlich nicht interessiert,
dann machst du das halt, ja, findest da vielleicht...
Da sind vielleicht auch ein paar ein oder andere interessante Sachen drin, ja, das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt für die Firma relevant und wichtig sein,
aber übrigens auch ein Punkt, wo ich sagen würde, bei allen Leuten, oder bei den meisten Leuten, das ist so eine Gemeinsamkeit,
bei Leuten, von denen ich sagen würde, die haben richtig Ahnung, ist, dass sie eine gewisse ordentlich, wie was ordentlich ist, Vorstellung haben.
Und mit ordentlich meine ich nicht, dass die Leute ordentlich sind, das schon mal gar nicht.
Ja, ich...
Die haben aber eine gewisse Vorstellung davon, wie man technische, ja, Projekte, na, Projekte ist falsch, wie man technische Sachen umsetzt, sodass sie sich gut anfühlen, ja.
Das ist egal, ob das jetzt aus Infrastruktursicht ist, aus Deploymentsicht, aus Anwendungsentwicklersicht, ist eigentlich egal, aber alle diese Leute haben eine gewisse Vorstellung.
Also die könnten sich da auch manchmal ein bisschen abweichen von, es gibt dann wilde Diskussionen und sowas, aber oftmals sind die gar nicht so sehr voneinander weg, ja.
Die haben eine gewisse Vorstellung, wie muss was ordentlich sein.
Zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal was, ja.
Also, wir haben es jetzt lange Zeit so gemacht für ein Projekt, wir haben unsere Cloud-Infrastruktur immer, ja, schnell, schnell hingebaut, weil irgendeiner mal irgendwo was testen wollte, ja.
Das heißt, wir hatten für jede Umgebung, also es gibt ein Entwicklungsprojekt, es gibt ein Integrationsprojekt, es gibt ein Produktionsprojekt, so.
Und wir haben da ein paar Terraform-Files angelegt, so einfach immer random hingeschmissen für jedes Projekt, kein gemeinsames Modul, wo alle drauf zugreifen, einfach ein paar Zeilen reingeklatscht.
Gestartet, irgendwas wurde in der...
...in der Cloud aufgebaut und dann hast du dann zum jeweiligen Entwickler oder zum Tester gesagt, ah ja, gut, guck mal, da steht jetzt ein Cluster, guck mal, wie du damit klarkommst, so.
Und das ist nix, was sich ordentlich anfühlt.
Was wir jetzt gemacht haben ist, wir haben jetzt ein eigenes Modul gebaut, was uns unsere Datenbank so hinstellt, wie sie sein soll in der Cloud, uns den Cluster so hinstellt, wie er sein soll und auch schon ein paar Parameter in dem Cluster per Kubernetes-YAML einspielt,
bevor man...
...überhaupt sich einmalig dagegen authentifiziert, dass alles da ist, so.
Und das Modul wird jetzt als Base genommen für alle Umgebungen, nicht mal so einzelne, immer sich voneinander wegentwickelnde, ja, Infrastructure-as-Code-Stände und das ist was, wo ich denke, okay, das fühlt sich für mich irgendwie ordentlich oder nach einer sinnvollen Umsetzung an und das ist auch was, wovon Leute, die ich dafür halte, dass sie viel Plan haben, die haben einen...
...gewissen...
...gewisses Gespür dafür, wie man was...
...ordentlich ist vielleicht nicht so sehr das richtige Wort, wie man was, mir fällt aber auch nix besseres ein, wie man was...
...ja, ordentlich umsetzt, mir fällt kein besseres Wort für ein.
Nichts...
...gescheit, wie man was gescheit umsetzt, ja, genau.
Sinnvoll, rund, rund, ja, rund trifft's eigentlich ganz gut, genau.
Aber jetzt gucken wir mal weiter.
Genau.
Das haben auch viele von den Leuten, die sich überlegen, okay, wie können wir das jetzt, die einfach auch schon mal ein bisschen vorausdenken können oder ein bisschen um die Ecke denken können und sagen, hey, das ist zwar nice, Beispiel, ein ganz, ganz simples Beispiel, brauchst gar kein super krasses Technik-Know-how für, ja.
Zum Beispiel haben wir eine Domain, nennen wir es jetzt mal bla bla blub.projekt.
.googlecloud.blablabla.de
So.
Und dementsprechend hast du dann eine, eine Subdomain davon, beispielsweise für irgendeinen Web-Frontend, ist dann frontend.blablabla.projekt.google.blub.de
Das ist halt für'n Arsch, weil...
...niemand von dem...
...am Ende, fachlich, für das Frontend, sich da einloggen muss und da Dinger macht, sich das jemals merken kann.
Natürlich, die können sich das alles bookmarken, aber intuitiv ist es nicht.
Deswegen kam jemand auf die chlorreiche Idee und das fand ich gut, das hat sich gleich mit meinem, wie ich es als ordentlich und rund und sinnvoll empfinde, gedeckt, kam der um die Ecke und hat gemeint, sag mal Max, was hältst du davon, wenn wir die Domain einfach mal wegschmeißen und irgendwas Kürzeres nehmen?
Also ja, das finde ich ist eine gute Idee und jetzt haben wir quasi produktname.blablub.de für das Produktivsystem und da unten drunter haben wir dann sowas wie dev.projekt.blablub.de und sowas.
Das ist eigentlich viel naheliegender, ja.
Weil wen juckt's, dass das bei Google läuft?
Wen juckt's, was sonst noch irgendwie dabei ist?
Das muss einfach...
...muss einfach...
...unbegriffig sein, dass man sich das merken kann, dass man da auch draufkommt, wenn man nicht gerade einen Bookmark dahin hat.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal das Video weiter.
...so wirklich erbaut von Dingen, die so im Bereich BWL liegen. Das heißt Managementkompetenz...
Das ist wohl richtig. BWL ist natürlich, liebt ja jeder Techniker bekanntermaßen.
...Probleme mit Hilfe von irgendwelchen IT-Dingen zu lösen.
Auf der anderen Seite sind wir ja meistens nicht so wirklich erbaut von Dingen, die so im Bereich BWL liegen.
Das heißt Managementkompetenz...
Ja, ich hab einfach keinen Kopf gerade für krasse Broggers, Broggers-Stells.
...ist meistens nicht so unser Steckenpferd. Wirtschaftliches Denken auch nicht wirklich.
Mitarbeiterführung liegt auch nicht vielen von denen.
Und am Ende des Tages ist vor allen Dingen der Punkt Verantwortung bei Softwareentwicklern oft ein ganz großes Thema.
Denn, auch wenn das vielleicht keine populäre Meinung ist, aber ich bin der Meinung, dass Softwareentwickler ganz, ganz oft einfach keine Verantwortung übernehmen wollen.
Ja.
Einfach, weil sie...
Ich auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich.
Also, wenn es um Personalsachen geht, ich auch nicht.
Ich hab keinen Bock auf den Stress.
Und das Schlimmste ist ja gar nicht mal, wenn du Personal...
Dann kriegst du Ärger von unten und Ärger von oben.
Das Schlimmste ist, du musst dich permanent mit irgendwelchen anderen Menschen auseinandersetzen.
Da hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Und nicht einfach nur mit Menschen auseinandersetzen, sondern meistens auch noch in irgendwie ein bisschen aufgeladenen Konfliktsituationen nicht mit anderen Menschen.
Da hab ich einfach überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Nicht in ihrer Komfortzone liegt, das heißt Verantwortung für Mitarbeiter...
Ja, so kann man das auch sehen.
Natürlich, so kann man auch sagen, ich will das gar nicht mehr, ich widerstrebe das richtig.
Ich hab da keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, Komfortzone trifft es wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Aber das ist so eine Komfortzone, mit der bin ich auch vollkommen fein.
Ich hab da gar keinen inneren Antrieb dagegen, ja.
Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, guck mal.
Ja, andere Sachen, wo ich jetzt gesagt hab, hey, guck mal.
Fahrradfahren ist sicherlich auch nicht in meiner Komfortzone.
Aber ich hab mir trotzdem ein Fahrrad gekauft und hab jetzt angefangen, Fahrrad zu fahren.
So.
Das ist was, weil ich mir von mir aus überlegt hab, okay, Max, das wär doch mal wieder was.
Und da musste ich mich auch dazu überwinden jetzt erstmal, ja.
Aber auf diese Sache, die Arbeit, hab ich halt einfach keinen Bock, will das auch gar nicht machen
und seh auch für mich nicht den Anlass, das irgendwie jetzt ändern zu wollen.
Möchten Softwareentwickler nicht Verantwortung für Prozesse, auch nicht Verantwortung für Architekturen,
auch wenn das nah an der Softwareentwicklung ist.
Ist auch ein bisschen.
Ein schwieriges Thema.
Das heißt, Softwareentwickler scheuen sich meiner Meinung nach einfach viel zu oft davor,
genau da Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Ja, ja, ist so.
Und genau das ist meine Theorie.
Je weiter wir jetzt auf dieser Karriere nach oben steigen, im Team oder besonders in der Organisation,
umso mehr Management-Anteile müssen wir übernehmen.
Umso mehr Verantwortung müssen wir übernehmen für Personal, für Prozesse, für Produkte.
Umso mehr Mitarbeiter müssen wir auch führen.
Auf der anderen Seite entfernen wir uns aber von Karrierestufe zu Karrierestufe immer weiter,
von dem, was wir als Softwareentwickler wirklich lieben, was unsere Passion ist,
nämlich die Softwareentwicklung, das Schreiben von tatsächlichem Quellcode.
Das heißt, je weiter ich nach oben gehe, umso weniger...
Das fände ich ja in Stellenanzeigen auch immer so gut.
Deine Passion ist das sowieso, wieso du brennst für das und das und das.
Diese Formulierungen sind mittlerweile so ausgelutscht.
Weniger habe ich direkt mit dem Quellcode zu tun, bis zu der Ebene irgendwann,
wo ich gar keine IDE mehr öffne, wo ich gar keinen Quellcode mehr schreibe,
sondern nur noch den ganzen...
Okay, okay.
Wenn ich mir das so überlege, also ich könnte mir...
Also wenn ich Java-Entwickler wäre, was ich ja glücklicherweise nicht bin,
wenn ich Java-Entwickler wäre, könnte ich mir doch vorstellen, Architekt zu werden,
um meine IDE nicht mehr zu öffnen,
vorausgesetzt, ich bin auch dazu gezwungen, Eclipse zu verwenden.
Dann wäre wahrscheinlich...
Chat, was meint ihr?
Was ist der bessere Weg?
Weiterhin Eclipse benutzen oder Teamleiter werden?
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Teamleiter werden, ne?
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, also...
Eclipse benutzen müssen ist schon hart, an der Grenze.
...mit Managementaufgaben, mit Personalführung oder sonst irgendwelchen Dingen beschäftigt bin.
Aber ist das Ganze jetzt ein Problem?
Echt, ist Eclipse brauchbar? Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab da...
Ich hab schon...
Eigentlich ist es eher so gemimt.
Ich hab Eclipse, glaube ich, schon die letzten...
...bestimmt 13 Jahre nicht mehr geöffnet.
Ich denke nicht, dass das ein Problem ist.
Wir Softwareentwickler lieben unseren Job.
Oder die letzten 10 Jahre nicht mehr geöffnet.
Für uns ist...
Aber 10 Jahre.
Für uns ist das nicht nur ein Job, sondern es ist mehr oder weniger unsere Passion.
Wir haben schon Softwareentwickler...
Was ist Eclipse?
Das hier.
Wahnsinnig tolle Auflösung.
Das ist Eclipse.
Das ist ein Typ...
Das ist ein schönes Beispiel für...
Ja, man erkennt das richtig gut.
Hi-Res, Hi-Res-Build.
Ja.
So sieht das aus.
Bevor wir im Beruf waren.
Wir haben Hobbyprojekte gehabt.
Wir programmieren manchmal nach der Arbeit.
Wir sitzen im Urlaub teilweise auf den Sonnenliegen und haben Bücher über Softwareentwicklung dabei.
Ich hab in jedem Urlaub eigentlich ein Buch dabei.
Zu Anforderungen, zu Architekturen, zu Prozessen oder was auch immer.
Auf der Gegenseite hab ich aber noch nie einen BWL-Menschen gesehen, der irgendwo in der Ferienanlage...
Das stimmt.
Das ist ein guter Vergleich.
Den find ich cool.
...liege liegt und ein Buch zu Steuerrecht liest zum Beispiel.
Das erlebe ich...
Das stimmt.
Ohne Scheiß, ne?
Da sieht man's doch schon mal wieder.
Das ist eigentlich ein richtig gutes Beispiel.
Daran sieht man's doch schon mal wieder.
Und das ist auch genau das, was ich vorher versucht hab...
Also eines der Sachen, die ich vorher versucht hab zu beschreiben, ja?
Ein Softwareentwickler oder irgendein IT-Techniker...
Einer von der Sorte, die ich vorhin beschrieben hab.
Die lesen im Urlaub auch irgendeinen Design-Pattern-Buch...
Oder, keine Ahnung, Advanced Kubernetes Administration oder irgendwie sowas.
Wohingegen irgendwie der krasse, komm in die Gruppe, yeah, wir werden reich BWLer, der guckt sich im Urlaub wahrscheinlich lieber irgendwie an, woraus sich demnächst besaufen geht oder so.
Echt?
Ist das so?
Kennst du...
Ja, Moment, aber weil die gerade studieren, oder?
Sicherlich, weil die gerade studieren.
Also...
Kennst du BWLer?
Die, sagen wir mal, seit 15 Jahren in, frag mich nicht, in irgendeinem Controlling-Job arbeiten.
Und die lesen dann im Urlaub die neuesten BWL-Trends 2023 oder so.
Okay.
Vielleicht gibt's die doch.
Mag sein, dass ich da auch nicht so viele einfach kenne, wo das so ist.
Vielleicht gibt's das, vielleicht gibt's das auch, ja.
Ja, aber sowas von.
Gibt es eigentlich noch, ähm, wie heißt das andere, was zwischenzeitlich auch mal recht beliebt war?
Net Beans, gell?
Net Beans, ja.
Gibt's...
Gibt's das noch?
Taugt...
Und vor allem taugt...
Das ist doch bestimmt auch kacke mittlerweile, oder?
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute verwenden halt einfach IntelliJ, weil das Jetbrains-Zeug in allen Sprachen ziemlich gut ist, wo es was für gibt.
Mal gucken, wie die Rust-Idee wird.
Wurde B.
Echt...
Keine Ahnung.
...nur bei Softwareentwicklern.
Ich habe auch schon viele andere Softwareentwickler im Urlaub gesehen, die genau solche Bücher eben auch dabei haben.
Dass Softwareentwicklung unsere Passion im Job ist, das ist im Jobbereich natürlich nichts Besonderes.
Es gibt viele andere Bereiche, viele andere Berufe, wo natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Passion mit dem Spiel ist.
Aber ich denke mal...
Nico Ryder ist Beste.
Das stimmt dem ja hoffentlich auch zu, dass wir in der Softwareentwicklung einen hohen Anteil von Menschen haben, deren absoluter Passion die Softwareentwicklung ist.
Es gibt natürlich einige, für die ist es ein Job, für die ist es ein 9-to-5.
Ja.
Aber für viele ist es eben genau das.
Aber die, die richtig krass Ahnung haben, die...
Eine Passion bedeutet, dass man diese Tätigkeit, diese...
Die interessiert sich nicht nur im Job dafür.
Und je weiter wir jetzt in der Karrierestufe aufsteigen, wie schon gesagt, umso weiter entfernen wir uns als Softwareentwickler von dem, was wir wirklich lieben.
Und genau das ist das Problem, wenn Softwareentwickler oftmals in Führungspositionen gehoben werden sollen.
Und meine Theorie, dass wir schlicht und ergreifend so zufrieden mit dem sind, was wir machen, dass wir so zufrieden sind mit der Softwareentwicklung,
das Ganze so gerne machen, dass wir gar nichts anderes machen wollen, dass wir genau diese Tätigkeiten als Schnöde,
als langweilig empfinden und eben lieber Techie sein wollen als irgendein Manager am Ende des Tages.
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen komisch, aber ich finde das Ganze zeichnet uns als Softwareentwickler irgendwo auch aus und ich finde diese Eigenschaft ganz schön cool.
Bei mir ist es nicht anders gewesen.
Ich bin damals bei Microsoft gewesen als Student Partner und hatte eigentlich meine Karriere bei Microsoft schon so ein bisschen ausgeguckt,
was man machen könnte, welchen Karriereweg man einschlagen konnte.
Und als ich dann gemerkt habe, was das wirklich bedeutet und dass ich sehr, sehr schnell von der Softwareentwicklung,
von der eigentlichen Programmierung, von der Architektur, von den Teams, von den Softwareentwicklungsteams wegkomme,
wollte ich das irgendwann gar nicht mehr machen und da habe ich mich dann entschlossen eben genau das zu meiner Selbstständigkeit zu machen,
dass ich das quasi bis zum Ende meines Lebens machen kann oder wenn ich dann irgendwann mal die Nase voll habe, mich anders entscheiden kann.
Ja gut, da brauchst du aber auch relativ viel BWL-Stocks-Knowledge.
Softwareentwicklung kann man eine ganze Menge Dinge richtig machen.
Das ist einer davon in meinen Augen, aber man kann auch ein paar Dinge falsch machen.
Und sehr verwandt mit diesem Thema ist das Video hier und wenn du alles richtig machen willst als Softwareentwickler, dann solltest du dir das,
als nächstes machen.
Ich wünsche dir jetzt einen schönen Tag, viel Spaß bei der Arbeit, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Du kannst halt nicht super krass Technik-Kellerkind sein und noch der krasse Checker.
Ich sage nicht, dass es keine gibt, aber die meisten haben das halt in Kombination nicht so drauf.
Jung und chancenlos, warum nicht alle in Ausbildung kommen?
Ja, das liegt an vielfältigen Sachen, aber sicherlich nicht nur an den Bewerbern, sondern auch an der anderen Seite.
Leute, was ist das?
Was ist jetzt angesagt?
Wer weiß es?
21.57 Uhr.
Gleich Bettke, richtig.
Puma müde.
Oh, meine Hand tut innen weh.
Ich habe echt, ich habe viel zu stark mich auf den Lenker gestürzt heute.
Oh, Chatke.
Was soll ich euch wieder vorstellen?
Das war jetzt aber nicht so HRQ-Chat.
War klar, das war klar, dass wir da irgendeinen Eingang machen.
Nee, ich bin jetzt wahrscheinlich sogar noch eine halbe Stunde wach.
Aber dann Bettke-Time.
Heute im Stehen schlafen wegen Fahrradbobbes.
Nee, im Liegen geht das.
Es geht jetzt auch im Sitzen hier gar kein Problem.
Nur wenn ich mich so nach vorne setze, sodass ich halt voll auf meinen Sitzknochen sitze, dann merke ich es.
Okay, Leute, bis morgen früh.
Übliche Zeit, wie immer.
Ich gucke, dass ich diesmal fertig mit meiner Laufrunde bin.
Rechtzeitig.
Rechtzeitig, dass ich bis spätestens neun am Start bin.
Bis morgen früh, macht's gut.
See you.